thank you
in what may be
a shocking pull to each and every one of
you a majority of Americans now believe
that Joe Biden
is not competent I know calm down I I
hope you are sitting down for this one
because there's more
another poll found that Kamala Harris
was also not competent
this has been a tough day for all of us
um
I mean we've been uh you know Ian was
crying when he found out I I wasn't
pulled which was the worst part
he's coming in
all I wanted for Christmas uh I don't
think anybody should be surprised by
this polling concerning everything
that's happening
um look he's not answering questions
about Afghanistan he's muttering and
sputtering he's not giving out like he's
not doing he's done a few of these you
know press uh uh uh events but there was
one instance where I guess he got asked
a question and then he went wait I
thought the question was supposed oh
anyway like the journalist agreed to a
question like it was all pre-planned but
then they threw him a curveball and he
was like uh and everyone's joking like
well that journalist is never getting
invited again yeah because Joe Biden
can't handle spontaneous questions do
you guys remember when he was like uh
they're gonna get mad at me for
answering questions so yeah we have this
to talk about we have a lot to talk
about um the FDA has approved the Pfizer
vaccine there's a lot of talk about
there because as much as for a lot of
people they're probably excited to hear
there's you know they were waiting for
FDA approval it just it means we're
gonna see a lot more vaccine mandates
which I think absolutely crossed the
line and this is where things start
getting creepy and weird and then we got
the recall election recall Gavin Newsom
and Larry Elder who has been smeared as
the black face of white supremacy
because of course as you know we live in
a Dave Chappelle sketch so uh it should
be fun so uh joining us today is Chris
Carr executive editor for timcast.com
yeah absolutely it's a thrill to be here
it's super exciting
um I I love being here I mean I don't
know what else to say I'm a bit of an
oddball I'm an introvert I'm a writer so
I'm gonna work on speaking right on
um but uh but yeah so prior to that I
was a news reporter in Southern
California for the epoch times so I'm
used to California Shenanigans I was
talking to Sour Patch earlier I said I'm
a bit desensitized to the insanity
coming out of California but I look
forward to talking about that among
other things right thanks for having me
yeah absolutely and and for those that
are wondering executive editor means uh
he makes sure the website's working and
all the news articles are going up so we
decided you know like let's let's you
know let's let's uh promote some of what
we're doing here man we got uh Chris is
great helping to make sure all the news
articles are going up on time if you go
to timcast.com you can check all that
stuff out and we are expanding and
building and hiring more journalists and
it's all it's all new it's all new so
we're getting there but uh we got we got
we got stuff coming we got Ian what up
hey is it confirmed that it's called
Epoch times and not Epic Times both
pronunciations are correct I say Epoch
because I'm from Appalachia so that's
you know just naturally where my accent
goes oh now you're back yeah happy to be
back yeah totally right on all right
well there you go good to be here thanks
Tim yeah I guess we're doing the Vlog
more and more yeah production's been
ramping up and we just we got the music
equipment for the new studio and the
latest Vlog Ian jamming out people are
people are but I can hear it when I do
when we do a jam night the next day my
voice is like Friday yeah yeah but we're
we're trying really hard to get these
Live Events ready to go so we might just
have to just try and duct tape some kind
of live event together because we better
do it now yeah we'll we'll we'll talk
about it afterwards because we've been
trying to do it for months and we've
been jammed up with red tape and lack of
duct tape so maybe we just make it
happen right we moved a bunch of
instruments into the Green Room so we
had a bunch in the garage kind of out
with the three printer equipment but it
was really a lot of stuff in a little
room so it's hard to jam out there and
get really humid so last night we moved
everything down to the studio the you
know the green room and it was really
it's a nice Chill Spot so we could have
like 20 or 30 people chilling down there
and listening that's always been the
plan is like mix it up but there's
there's bureaucratic stuff holding us up
so I think we've got to figure it out
but we will we got the uh we got lady
all the buttons I am indeed pressing all
the buttons I'm really excited to be
sitting in a room full of all my
co-workers it's gonna be a great time
I'm looking forward to what Chris has to
say we're having fun talking before the
show yes that's right all right but my
friends before we get into all of that
news we have an amazing sponsor we have
bio trusts keto Elevate C8 MCT oil
powder now accidentally I find myself uh
doing the keto diet it's just because we
did this crab day thing where we went
and bought a bunch of crab which is all
like protein and then we bought a bunch
of meat and cheese to make like a
charcuterie thing and so that was all I
ended up eating and whipped cream and
fruits and stuff and then I just find
myself feeling better cutting down the
sugars dramatically and so I've been
really ramping up this stuff I love this
stuff the the BioTrust keto Elevate it's
a medium chain triglyceride power powder
but in my coffee it's it's almost like a
creamer it's fantastic and then I just
put a little heavy cream in there it's
amazing I love it so go to eat right and
feelwell.com you can get 51 off of your
order of Keto Elevate MCT the oil powder
then when you go to their website eat
write and feelwell.com you get a 60 day
money back guarantee the keto Elevate
provides your body with only C8 the most
ketogenic MCT that means it provides
support for energy levels healthy
appetite Management Mental Clarity and
focus athletic performance 5 grams of
the highly sought after mctc8 per scoop
keto Elevate is my favorite MCT powder
on the market that is true free shipping
on every order and for every order today
BioTrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kidhungry.org to
date BioTrust has has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
BioTrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year and you get free VIP
live health and fitness coaching with
BioTrust from from BioTrust team of
expert nutrition and health coaches for
life with every order that's massive and
their new e-report the top 14 kinogenic
foods with every order now I will add
one more thing go to eat right and
feelwell.com but I saw you guys in the
chat somebody was saying that Tim
fidgets all the time and they're making
fun of me because I'm always like you
know moving around and stuff yeah it's
got too much energy it's true though
putting that keto Elevate I feel like
you know I'm just so so so energized and
I really do fidget all that's hard for
me to sit still because I'm like ready
to go I'm ready to you know but uh also
head over to timcast.com become a member
we're gonna have a members only segment
coming up after the show usually usually
goes up around 11 or so pm and you will
also get an ad free experience and
support our amazing team of journalists
and our expansion to hire more and more
journalists so check that out now
let's get in oh wait smash the like
button subscribe share the show now
let's get into that story from
timcast.com majority of Americans no
longer believe that Biden is competent
do you know you know if it wasn't on
timcast.com I'd almost assume this
article was fake news you know why
it implies that at some point people did
believe Joe Biden was competent right
so now they don't this is the one thing
well you know what it is is that people
live in the media so when the media is
saying Biden's great everyone's like
okay and now that he's botching
Afghanistan and the media is criticizing
him now the people who don't pay
attention are all of a sudden shocked to
realize but he's doing bad and isn't it
funny how these polls track with the
mainstream media narrative they say
according to a new poll from CDs 51
believe that Biden is not a competent
commander-in-chief well 49 believe that
he is I'd like to meet at least one of
these 49 percent
who are these people that believe after
everything we've seen the pollsters also
found that 52 of likely voters do not
feel the president has been focused
I just I just who's this 48 that has
heard the man speak and heard the word
true and on a shop at a pressure and
decided that that was focused I know
those people they're my family they're
my friends there's tons of people oh
yeah I know I mean that's true and I
don't think you could throttle them into
reality I really don't yeah you know and
that's really sad and it's unfortunate
for me because it's cost me friendships
it's cost me a lot but I those 49 of
people do exist and I don't think that
they're necessarily willing to wake up
to what's actually happening yeah it's
it's it's it's safe yeah we've got these
baby chicks okay we that we've had we
had we had I think 14 eggs and we're not
good at what we're doing so most of them
didn't make it but three of them did and
they're actually pretty spunky and
strong
and they are scared to leave their
little brooder box it's safe it's warm
now one of them though is always like
peeking out you know and it wants
there's one that that one that's Brave
and that's that's what this reminds me
of the two out of the three they're like
scared and they're just like I don't
want to leave it's warm and safe don't
make me go I don't want to go in the
real world and I I look at them and I'm
like they would have voted for Joe Biden
it's it's just easy you know it's you
don't got to think it's like you know we
hear from these YouTubers like you don't
even gotta think you just go to the
website and it's all done for you here's
where it gets here here's where uh well
this is interesting the CBS poll was
conducted as Afghanistan fell to the
Taliban and 53 disagreed with the way
that the troops were withdrawn 70
percent said the removal of troops could
have been handled better along with 55
percent who said some troops could have
stayed according to Breitbart News Now
the sad part is we'll go to the bottom
there's a couple things here Rasmussen
found that 55 of Voters believe Harris
is not qualified to assume the duties of
the presidency including 47 percent who
said she is not qualified at all wow
jeez that's harsh what 43 of likely
voters believe she is ready to be the
president way down from 49 back in April
a couple interesting things Civics shows
Joe Biden's job approval by state in
almost every single state Joe Biden is
underwater with disapproval it is
California Connecticut New Jersey New
York Hawaii Oregon Illinois Rhode Island
Maryland Massachusetts Vermont and
Washington that have a positive view of
Joe Biden yeah
basically blue states of course count on
it the craziest thing about all this I
suppose is it's it's independent voters
are driving all of this Republicans hate
Biden and Democrats love Biden and
that's not changing but independent
voters are are are shifting away 57
disapprove of Joe Biden so I don't know
what this means I mean maybe we'll get a
25th Amendment
I'm really shaken with his uh his
behavior in the last couple weeks it's
nice to see the polls like this catching
up I don't know did you catch so many
people were pulled or if it was like a
nationwide poll uh well Civics is 91 514
responses but that's over a couple years
um I don't know I can pull up the CBS
one though I when this Afghanistan thing
went down I don't know if it was
intentional and they're like you're
gonna make us pull out fine we'll show
you what a pull out looks like here suck
it or if it was just Biden was so is
such a poor military commander he's the
commander-in-chief of the U.S armed
forces he's such a poor military
commander that he just didn't understand
tactics like you leave air support in
while you move people out on the ground
it could have been a three-month process
moving people out he had he hadn't he
had all year and they rushed it new so
it's 2142 adults with a margin of error
margin of era of plus two point three
percent two thousand that's a that's a
big sample all right I got like a Pang
of fear thinking what if this stupid
Chinese Boogeyman the CCP but like if
they're was some sort of like
coordinated Invasion right now with
Biden at the helm if he really doesn't
isn't a good commander and then we have
to fight a war we lose because the
commander misappropriates the first days
or the most
you know vulnerable moments in a war you
know you know I think this people that
were saying that
Afghanistan has revealed the emperor has
no clothes
and you know what's crazy to me is this
realization because I've actually even
though I know Joe Biden's kind of like
you know not all with it I still felt
like you know people say like oh who's
bought Biden's Handler who's really
pulling the strings oh it's going to be
kamalan you see Afghanistan it's like
dude they're they're legit following
Biden and so when Biden mutters stutters
and stammers and falls asleep they just
sit there
like I genuinely thought there were
people like picking up the slack for
Biden after all this I it's like people
were M.I.A like where was Kamala she
wasn't speaking now you've got this
video where she's walking out and the
reporters like I want to ask you about
if you know the people and she's like no
and people are like why why is she
laughing she laughs at really weird
times she's a weird person yeah yeah I
don't know man I think that Biden did
have people picking up the slack for him
and I'm afraid that the people who are
doing that for Joe were people like Mark
milley people who are focused on things
like white rage no instead of what it
would have been like to pull out
properly I think Mark milley is is an
example of the fact that Biden's just
sleeping they probably walk in the Oval
Office he's like and then Mark Milly's
like yes
you know that No One's Gonna fire me now
because Biden's asleep he can't do it
unless he wakes up yeah maybe yeah how
do we have these people woke generals
chaos it's the end of the American
Empire I forget which commentary I
listened to mentioned this but you just
see Joe Biden you see him walking away
from these press conferences he seem
walking up to the podium this is not the
face of a healthy democracy it just I
mean it it's and it's painful to watch
it really is and I I feel those pangs
that you're talking about when I see him
speak and and it's at a certain point it
just it it it's not even funny you know
I mean like some people still just kind
of want to pile on doing and make fun of
him and it's not funny it feels like he
is uh genuinely struggling to put
together a sentence to put together a
perspective and to lead the nation and
how is it only now I guess I made the
point right people were following the
media but only now these independent
voters are like hmm maybe this you know
79 78 year old is gonna be 79 soon 78
year old guy who can't talk well is
something wrong with him that's that's
what I was going to ask you what do you
think it was it was the strawberry broke
the camel's back but essentially was it
Afghanistan or was it just like this was
the final thing the latest thing that's
really just made people kind of see
what's happening this is what's scary
about it is that it's whatever CNN tells
them yeah you know and and CNN's like
Biden's great and they're like okay and
now Afghanistan like CNN wants war war
is good for the for the bottom line for
all these media companies now they're
like oh he really messed this one up and
now regular people are like CNN said he
messed it up so he did
there you go the funny thing is he
hasn't lost in the Civics poll shows
Biden hasn't lost a single percentage
point from Democrats since the fall of
Kabul till today
like I just
it's it's it's it's a cult I wish I
could say it surprised me honestly but
it doesn't and it is a cult yeah yeah I
see that here's the thing about Trump
trump was giving a speech and he told
everyone to go get the vaccine and they
booed him yeah and I'm I'm laughing like
oh geez but that doesn't that prove it's
not a cult even Trump's most dired
supporters are like no Trump you're
wrong that's that's that to me that's
kind of that says a lot and I think that
shows that uh Trump is the avatar for
that working-class anger these people
are not blindly following Trump a lot of
them are yeah a lot of them are a lot of
but but taboo him when he said that
there's there's
yeah they they they they said no Trump
is not the end I'll be all but Biden
people just say go Biden Sam Harris
tweeted something you got you guys don't
say yourself yeah and he was like unlike
you know the Trump supporters that
blindly just defend Trump you know I'm
gonna criticize Joe Biden it's like oh
you're so brave you and CNN criticizing
Joe Biden wow for once that's really
unfortunate about Sam Harris I really
think that he's one of the public
intellectuals who got broken in some
sense during a lockdown I think I think
something like triggered in his brain
and he hasn't recovered in some sense
because used to I would be able to
listen to him and I would hear coherent
thoughts even when I disagreed but
lately he's just been on some sort of
bandwagon that doesn't even follow up
with a lot of the stuff he used to claim
what happened to people I know I know
yeah I got a story about that actually
and this is it really hit home with me
because like my best friend 15 years
we've we've been best friends for a
really long time
and I sent him a text message I was like
did you see the key to NYC situation
yeah and well he's a Chicago guy you
know blue put all the way Lori Lightfoot
supporter you know still still
um and uh he so I I told him about the
key to NYC program I was like you saw
this right he's like yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] great oh sorry sorry that's what
he said he said this is this is effing
great and I was just like this is
fascism he said I don't care if it is I
love it this is exactly what needs to
happen there need these mandating to be
in a place and people need to follow in
line or not and I said I didn't realize
that you were a fascist I had no I
didn't realize you became radicalized
yeah and he said Chris we're gonna have
to disagree on this and I said no no
we're not disagreeing you're disagreeing
with the definition of fascism yeah and
he goes do you want to still be friends
or are you going to let this go it's a
simple question
I got its answer I mean but but it's not
just screw off I don't know I I haven't
heard from him since and I didn't
message him back actually I did message
him I said that sounds exactly like
something a fascist would say
but but but it's it these kind of
derangement fits happen on personal
levels and they also happen in these
kind of national displays like on
Twitter and I see more and more of that
and it's really disturbing to me I I
love this reference I used the Galaxy
Quest one you guys have seen Galaxy
quests yeah oh yeah Tim Allen yeah Tony
shalhoub's character is just like
laughing they're they're they're TV
actors on a spaceship they're gonna die
and he's just like I guess we're gonna
die whatever he's laughing that's kind
of how I feel about everything you know
not not to like downplay it but people
often say like how did you know Nazi
Germany get to the point to violate
Godwin's law outright how did how did
Nazi Germany get to that point it's like
you're sitting here right now like New
York is mandating identification and and
uh uh proof of vaccination to enter a
restaurant it's like I I get it if you
want to if you're concerned about your
health and there's a medication it's FDA
approved taking congratulations you can
go to doctor and you can figure it out
for yourself but for the city to be like
fire all of your disabled employees like
uh we've we've certainly crossed a line
here and what's funny is I taught you
you saw you mentioned about your friend
they're cheering for it yeah they are
they're they're they love it not crazy
they feel like their tribe is winning
right I mean isn't isn't there some sort
of like very basic tribal element to
this yeah
yeah
man
but what but but there's no I guess
these people don't understand that
they're not they're not in the the
actual tribe of elitism those that run
the systems and are locking everything
down will throw them into the gutter at
a moment's notice but so they're just in
there gloating saying haha I'm in the
winning team and I'm like I don't care
who's leave me alone you can go like I
feel like I'm watching a hockey game and
they're like just playing really
aggressive and I'm not playing the game
and I'm like just get get away from me
and they're trying to throw me into the
rink to play and I'm like no they just
and and now they're throwing stuff at
the stands and I'm like yeah why you're
throwing stuff at me like I got nothing
to do with your games would you fight to
protect people that hated you
that's a good question hmm
I guess there's a lot of uh Nuance in
that question though I don't know how to
answer it like if you're destined to be
a villain even if you protect the people
if there was like some do if there was
like an antifa guy and he was like
yelling and cussing at me and then like
you know he was like walking away and a
car was speeding at him full speed I'd
probably try and save him yeah you know
that's the GI Joe in you well it's just
like the dude you're allowed to hate me
man you know like if the guy's not being
violent toward if he was violent towards
me I'd probably I'd probably be like nah
I'm not gonna get anywhere near this guy
but it's not a good idea but if there
was like someone who's like I hate you
you're dumb and then I saw a car coming
I'd be like look out and I try and save
him so there's a difference between
being violent towards you and hating you
I suppose that's where there's some
Nuance there yeah if they're like
throwing rocks at me I'd just be like no
I'm not going anywhere near that guy you
know what about you Ian but based on
your question yeah I would you're very
thankless
also I wonder like if you're preserving
like low intelligence humans that just
eat and reproduce and eat and reproduce
and then starve out the system if you're
actually doing a disservice to the
species
I don't know it's weird right it's very
ethical and like um what's the genetic
what's that
um yeah eugenic it's very eugenic way to
look at like should they live or should
they die but I mean that's basically
what governments do and you know I'll
tell you this for a fact that these
these uh powerful interests have asked
themselves these questions
no no doubt about it because uh uh when
we had Alex Jones here I asked him that
question on the show
what if the the all of this stuff about
the end you know the end and he
overpopulation is true and we as humans
are just yeast in a bottle consuming all
the resources and farting ourselves to
death and he said you know Alex said
he's like I asked myself that question
all the time but
how do you answer it it's it's it's a
legitimate question the problem is you
know I can't remember exactly what he
said but he was like you know you got to
defend freedom and liberty we no
individual person is going to be smart
enough to steer the ship properly and we
can rely on human nature which has
always found Solutions through Ingenuity
and invention or we can just hand it off
some despot authoritarian who we know
through history has always oppressed
murdered and punished it's tough man it
you know because we we're at what like
eight billion people there I was like
insect populations declining there's
dead zones in the ocean and the point
you brought up is actually brought up by
a lot of people
there's a a lot of conspiracy theory
people write about how the elites view
humans as useless eaters they don't
contribute anything they don't do
anything they just consume make waste
and reproduce and so there's a very
difficult questions in that how many
people do you know and and everyone
probably does who do nothing
literally nothing or they work a job
that's just like yeah not beneficial
yeah like insurance
well people made up a good point about
insurance brokers for like big
corporations when you have specialty
contracts that I understand but there
are probably a lot of jobs that uh don't
do anything for the system at all
probably tons of them that are just like
well someone's you gotta have a job I
guess right banking
banking's weird that's a weird
maybe maybe we're we're advancing to the
point where we can say that
I think banking makes sense I think
Central Banking has corrupted the whole
process that's a different thing the
profit motive of banking is pretty weird
yeah I understand I want to get screwed
on your loan so you charge you know a
little bit of interest but to try and
get rich off of extracting value from
from the system without contributing
anything to that system right so I
always complain about people who you
know or I should say I complain about
how the the government's printing a lot
of money giving it to people so they're
able to buy stuff take food and
resources from the system without
putting anything in and that creates a
trade imbalance which a production and
balance which eventually causes collapse
and uh but we say that with a lot of
people in financial jobs
they they make bets they extract from
the system they don't do anything but
that's that's that's that's that's I
wanna I wanna stay on what you what you
asked Ian because let's let's uh let's
just take a few minutes and get
philosophical real quick before we jump
over to the California stuff
what do you do if that's true Ian what
do you do if you have seven billion
people who don't contribute anything
they eat and they pollute and they
destroy
jeez dude
you have to build a system that allows
for that behavior without so that solves
the problem with taking into account the
the the the unchangeable human problem
which is that we're wild animal
consumers destructors uh so you build a
system where it's okay to be destructive
and and consumers like you need massive
expansion capability you need unlimited
access or relatively unlimited access to
resources like food
is it possible yeah it just takes a lot
of like re redesigning of the system
like we need fusion power we need
magnetic transportation we need to be
able to see them from place to place
that's what I'm talking about that if
you look at history the crises we've
always faced have been solved by
technology and the authoritarians who
are always screaming at the problems
have always just Mass murdered people so
if I'm gonna sit here and be like what
should we do I'd be like invent stuff
you know engineering uh scientific
research and development not handing
over the reins of government to crackpot
despots people like in the Democratic
party and the neocons formerly of the
Republican Party
because they'll just burn it down it's
faster and easier I guess and if you
come out independently and say I want to
burn it down then the system seeks you
out as as like a danger and will
incarcerate or destroy you I've found
too so there's either you join them and
then give up and that's you lose or you
try and you just give up on your own and
then you lose because you look like
you're messing with their version of of
how to
destroy the situation or how to you know
you can't be you can't be the famous one
doing it that's too dangerous for the
power structure so they'll
I think the the only the only way is to
is to help the people is to give them a
chance yeah I think we got to rely on
development
we were talking about helping people
like people that are in need like people
that can't help themselves like that
that aren't critical thinkers that are
draining on the system having seven
seven kids it's kind of like just a
fictitious idea of people in my head I
don't know no no it's not fictitious at
all but I don't think the seven kids is
the issue I think it's that I know tons
of people who sit around doing literally
nothing like they go out they eat they
party and they go home and they don't do
anything and their jobs are like menial
and and
I have no issue with their life choices
and the life they live and what they
choose to live because I'm not going to
sit here and decide what is or isn't
more important in anyone's life right
like oh you relaxing and doing garbage
work is well that's how they choose to
live their life but certainly there's a
mathematical equation that at a certain
point you're like we have 50 billion
people on the planet it's about to
implode or something like that you know
what I mean or maybe it's not maybe it's
not true maybe we'll never get to that
point maybe it's just tunnels but maybe
it's just fear-mongering so that people
give up control to lazy people who don't
want to work I look at these you know
you know what I see when I see like
these ultra wealthy people laziness now
I know it sounds it sounds contradictory
right and it's it's often like a leftist
trout but the reason why a lot of the
powerful leads I'm not saying every
single one want power is they don't want
to do anything
It's like because there's no point at
which you have money that you can just
stop and relax never never happens
and so there are people who are like how
can I just get to that point where me
and my friends don't have to do anything
anymore
authoritarianism
slaves yeah just if you have supreme
power over people then you truly can
relax and not have to work
I don't think that you can ever actually
really relax and not have to work though
I mean they you might have that
perception you might think that's
possible but ultimately you're going to
find that you have a purposeless life
and at once once you sense that either
consciously or unconsciously you're
going to start to act out and probably
lash out of people around you but what
about there's so many I guess actually
yeah I guess you're right probably maybe
maybe the issue is this there's a lot of
people with purposeless lives and we've
talked about this before and that's why
you're saying the rise of wokeness right
people in power with purposeless lives
yes yeah well I mean this goes back to
anecdote from Jordan Peterson when he
was working with somebody in his
clinical practice and they he was just
like well what do you want to do with
your life he's like well I just want to
relax on the beach and you know drink
Margaritas all day and he was just like
that's not a plan that's not even a
poster you know I mean like I mean it
sounds so great in theory but in
practice it does not work out not just
for the person themselves but for the
people that surround them you know their
family their friends their acquaintances
you know it spins out of control at some
point this is this is the craziest thing
about the anti-work subreddit have you
guys ever seen this no no r slash
anti-work
what what it's crazy how they view work
it's like do you just want to melt into
a chair and cease to exist work is life
and I don't mean I don't mean like
working at McDonald's I mean like your
goals your passion your mission it's all
you doing work people don't understand
this There's no distinction between uh
in the long run work and hobby or
Leisure like if you wake up every day
and you work really hard on
skateboarding that work can pay off you
are there it's just mind-blowing to me
people are like I don't want to work so
what are you gonna do all day eat food
you could be a competitive reader
congratulations like I don't understand
like what you're doing
is work
yeah yeah work is a scientific I'm
looking up the actual scientific
definition of it right now but I believe
it's just the uh the transition of
energy into Power uh the production of
power through what is it in joules you
can measure work in joules I believe so
like what I'm saying is this is work I'm
producing work to move this back and
forth the question is do you enjoy the
work you're doing you can sit still and
you're still working so do you if you
don't if you like what you're doing it
doesn't feel exhausting work doesn't
have to be negative and exhausting can
be super fun that's the key I think
they're always going to be working on
something even if it's just sitting
there trying to stay sane I think we've
got a bunch of Elites who basically
believe what you just said to start off
this a little bit that there's a lot of
people who just eat and don't do
anything and they're a problem and so
they're like let's just strip the system
down they're not creative enough to be
like how do we fix this how do we solve
for this problem they're just like
eradicate the problem yeah that's
[ __ ] dangerous man yeah I will say
the remote work now from the lockdowns
is a good thing you know why yeah
parents are gonna be with their kids
before it was like you know your kids
are being raised by the state that's a
problem now with remote work we saw that
there's a bunch of funny videos that
have emerged like there was that that
guy who was appearing on a news program
and his kid walks in and he's like oh
it's my kid and then what happened to a
woman too and I'm like that's good
they're seeing the cameras the kids are
going to learn they're going to
understand the work their parents right
there with them I think that's going to
have a profoundly positive impact we um
in
2010-11 I started working on mines
co-founded mines with Bill and we didn't
have an office we would just work from
home and it was the best it was for me
it was I worked in the restaurant
industry for a decade or whatever 15
years so bill was like I want to get an
office I want to just do like the the a
fish stereotypical like let's start a
tech company let's get an office we'll
have it and I'm like dude it just it
sucks to the commute blows so he we did
we got an office it sucked and the
commuting sucked it cost me like 50
bucks a day in commuting time sometimes
um yeah James your time and then your
energy we got rid of it no more office
you don't need an office especially a
social network doesn't need an office
right now we can do slack me you're
literally a social network I think you
have the internal technology to
communicate with each other incredible
you just do not need an office you're
almost incentivized not to to cut so
much cost is it sustainable though like
what what kind of economy are we going
to have left if all of our manufacturing
goes to China and then all Americans do
is run blogs right because if the power
goes out and everyone's in their house
in different parts of the country the
work day is over like I don't know what
the backup for that is if you're in an
office at least you can keep working
because you're in the room together I
guess your cell phone still works yeah
you might be able to pull it off with
solar panels well if your phone's
charged you can still talk to people but
I I the question I'm saying is we don't
make stuff anymore
if people are working remote the service
economy is going to get hit Mass that's
going to be massive like if if we're
working remotely we don't need to go to
local cafes anymore so everybody goes to
one office building and then for lunch
they all go down to little restaurants
down you know downstairs but if we're
all working remote you're eating at home
so this is actually one of the
contributors to the food shortages that
we've been seeing is that with the
lockdowns and people not working they
were cooking more so they were buying
base ingredients from supermarkets and
the shelves were depleted and so then
there was a big surge in orders but
people also weren't working anymore so
that means nobody was making the stuff
but anyway so it's a big contributing
factor when people aren't leaving
so all these restaurants one by one are
gonna start falling I think we're on the
I think people don't realize that it's
it's falling apart to the extent that it
is I think like these regular people who
for some reason think Biden's competent
man they're holding on and it's it's you
know what
I'm confident they're gonna have a long
fall but that's uh that's not my problem
well it might be because we're we're all
in this together right it's not just
something that's going to be doing the
fall he's the commander of the strongest
military Earth has ever seen that we
know of and he's like flubbing his words
mixing up North and South Korea doesn't
and Libya and Syria dude it's it's I
don't know I've never been in a war but
sometimes I put my head in in the in the
my mind in the place of someone that
isn't being invaded like a farmer and
once it happens it's it's done
everything is changed in a moment and it
doesn't there's no warning like I mean
you might get a warning but back in the
day they didn't get a warning people
just ride up and then they're there like
when the power goes out
then you'll start to wonder like oh yeah
did I I should have called my mom two
days ago or all the things you should
have done should have voted for Trump
should have got that extra bottle of
water should have bought that ammo
should uh Shoulda Shoulda and it's like
dude yeah yeah that's big news too that
Biden apparently banned Imports of
Russian ammo why yikes I don't know this
is economic what the heck and you know
it was funny because we got a bunch of
super chats from people and they were
like get ammo now Biden just banned
Russian Imports and I look at my phone
and it's Luke and he's like get ammo now
I'm like look when you get in here yeah
yeah let's talk about what's going on in
California though this is funny yeah
ladies and gentlemen I give you uh our
our
um
What's um okay who was the the guy who
wrote the story about uh the clown comes
out from behind the stage and tries to
warn the audience as a fire some
philosopher I don't know kicker guard
okay yeah yeah so here's the story first
Larry Elder brushes off LA Times column
that called him the black face of white
supremacy
okay okay uh Clayton Bigsby the Dave
Chappelle sketch is not real these
people are insane but this is a really
good example of the the kicker guard
story I think it's kickerd of the the
the clown he comes out from backstage
with a fire a fire has broken out and he
starts frantically waving to the
audience there's a fire in the back
everyone get out and they'll start
laughing laughing with joy and he the
clown gets frustrated and tries
desperately to tell them but the more
energetic he gets to warn about the fire
that's actually burning on the theater
the more they laugh
and then he says your guard says I
imagine that's you know how the world
will end you know that people you know I
forgot exactly what he said but the
people are going to be laughing not
realizing what's going on around them
when when okay look Larry Elder might
win this one and I think that would be
amazing he's a Libertarian guy he's he's
a smart fella and they are pulling out
every stop imaginable to try and block
Larry Elder from winning in California
now here's what you need to understand
Gavin Newsom will get recalled if people
vote to recall if they don't vote for my
here's my I could be wrong but my
understanding is if you walk in and say
recall and walk out
he gets recalled you don't need
necessarily to vote for someone to
replace him yeah that's exactly right
yeah get rid of them well you lived
under uh under Newsome right yeah I did
how was that I mean we I kind of lived
in a renegade County Orange County isn't
isn't quite like LA or San Diego
certainly not like San Francisco so uh
Orange County has a long history of uh
fighting back against
um sort of big metropolises like La I
mean Orange County used to be a part of
LA and then there was a big fight and
then they broke off and they were just
like we don't we don't want to have what
you guys are doing in La so um I had
that benefit so but at the same time I
mean yeah the lockdown was crazy I mean
it was it was total and it was complete
and everybody had to wear a mask I mean
I'll never forget the first time I I
encountered one of my friends on the
sidewalk and she goes the CDC so we can
take our masks off it was the first time
I'd seen her without a mask on wow such
a sweet lady but you know I mean I was
just like really you need the CDC to
tell you that outside when there's you
know it's 72 degrees every day and you
can enjoy you know the air and
everything so I mean but yeah that's the
mentality out there but based on you
living under him you think recall yeah
I talked to some political strategists
that have uh that not only have been
working California politics for decades
but they are actually actively working
with some of the people that are hoping
to replace Newsome as Governor Mike uh
oh yeah yeah Republicans uh yeah pretty
much all of them
um and uh they this was probably four
months ago and they said make do not
misunderstand this Gavin Newsom will not
lose he will not be recalled he will not
be replaced period there's just but this
is back when there was just a bunch of
like you know kind of half recognizable
clown names you know they were throwing
their hat there's one guy that was going
around California with a bear you
remember this yeah no oh yeah he would
he did like a couple uh speeches with a
with a bear but the bear wasn't even a
California bear so that was really
embarrassing
um uh so that was the worst of it yeah
yeah and the bear was like kind of bear
this bear was like you know looking
licking itself while he's trying to give
a speech it was it was you know that's
great so when you saw when you see stuff
like that you're just like okay I mean
but the political strategist that I
talked to would say things like no no
you have to understand that Gavin Newsom
they spoke off the record of course they
didn't want me to print what they said
they said Newsome is such a ruthless
conniving politician that he he is
absolutely not going to let anybody take
over for him as Governor Larry Elder's
changing that and you can see that he's
changing that by the by the total
derangement that you're seeing on the LA
Times I mean I saw a clause the other
day it was like it was like six titles
it was just like flinging every piece of
pasta that they possibly can at the wall
to see what sticks on this guy and it's
not working because Larry Alder makes
sense he's a sane guy I know but but
like
who in their right mind would call a
black man the face of white supremacy
well what is wrong with these people I
don't know
they're sick sometimes I feel like the
clown running out on the stage and going
and everyone's just laughing like and
I'm like
yeah yeah I told her about that because
I I try and have like levity in my life
and be kind of a jokester and not take
things too seriously but I wonder if if
a result of that is that people aren't
going to take me seriously when I'm
screaming about the fall the danger that
we're looking at I don't know let me let
me let me read a little bit read a
little bit of this they say uh the LA
Times published a column on Friday
titled Larry Elder is the black face of
white supremacy you've been warned Oh
Heaven which accuses the Republican of
using overly simplistic arguments that
whitewash the complex problems that come
along with being black in America LA
Times columnist Erica D Smith said Elder
uses taunting and toddler-like
name-calling of his ideological enemies
before belittling the gubernatorial
candidate with her own insults quote
I've learned that it's often best just
to ignore people like Elder people who
are as my dad used to say skin folk but
not Kinfolk she wrote before attempting
to insult Elder as a trump Fanboy
dangerous a troll and implied he doesn't
understand critical race Theory his
candidacy feels personal like an insult
to Blackness that Times columnist wrote
Fox News host Sean Hannity called the
column disgusting and invited Elder to
respond to it directly
quote I am genuinely friend a friend
sorry that you have to go through
something as evil horrific and racist as
that Henry said however Elder who leads
the pack of Republican candidates
looking to replace California Gavin
Governor Gavin Newsom wasn't surprised
quote I anticipated that would happen
this is why a lot of people don't go
into politics because of the politics of
personal destruction this is not the
first time the LA Times attacked me
there is another writer who all but
called me a black David Duke Ellington
wow they're scared to death that is
definitely true look at this Libs of
tick tock pulled this up this is great
let's pull this up love them they're
terrified of Larry Elder all of these uh
oh come on are you gonna you're gonna
give me the business I can't pull up the
photo anymore yeah I don't think it's
gonna let me okay well we can read some
of it Larry Elder the black face of
white supremacy Larry Elder talks a lot
too bad you can't believe anything he
says Larry Elder bashes the media offers
no Solutions remind you of an
ex-president no wow how many people in
California are like oh that's good you
know I do like Trump what is this oh yes
State officials open investigation into
whether Larry Elder failed to disclose
income sources
cheese if Larry Elder is elected life
will get harder for Black and Latino
Californians amazing that's my other
favorite one right there that's a good
one yeah they're really scared of this
guy he's leading the pack yeah he is and
this was not supposed to happen that's
what's so funny is that like it was just
guaranteed that this recall effort they
are branding it so hard as right-wing
Republican it's a right-wing recall vote
no on the Republican recall I mean they
are so desperate to Brand it that way
and people just aren't having it I know
Democrats in California that died in the
world Democrats voted for Biden they
vote for him again they said I'm still
voting yes on a recall oh yeah do you
think the recall is going to go through
I do
I do it's neck and necklace I really
want to be white pilled on this I really
do I mean I I it's gonna happen
you're gonna say something so yeah
Gavin do some Gabe where he was like
maniacal he looked like um what's his
name Bateman yeah when he was mayor of
San Francisco yeah yeah that was great
the reporter keeps trying to ask him
like logical questions about all the
problems that he's caused and he just
he's cackling and he he cuts off the
first uh question from the reporter I
believe and he just like starts naming
like numbers and stuff total Patrick
Bateman yeah yeah crazy person American
Psycho he owns it he owns the American
psychother yeah yeah he does well you
know when I saw him defying his own
covid mandates I was like despot get him
out yeah so I've seen the polling but
it's I I gotta say I guess it's not
entirely surprised that some Democrats
Democrats are like get rid of the guy
now here's where it gets really funny
from Newsweek well it's from Newsweek
but it's quoting 538 Nate silver calls
Democratic strategy to leave Newsome
recall candidate line blank
self-destructive
if Newsom gets recalled the Democrats
have offered up no one is that is that
what's going on so the only option you
have as a republican so Larry Elder is
going to win
wow I hadn't even thought about that
scenario that's crazy well so here's
what they say 538 founder Nate silver
said Monday the strategy California
Democrats are pursuing heading into next
month's gubernatorial recall election is
self-destructive as sitting Governor
Gavin Newsom faces the possibility that
he could be voted out of office the
Democratic party is encouraging
Californians to vote against removing
Newsome from office but to refrain from
selecting amongst the 46 replacement
candidates who appear on the recall
ballot okay so is are there there got to
be some Democrats newsom's campaign has
made similar recommendations in recent
weeks on Monday Silva responded to a
tweet posted by a political reporter who
suggested the strategy was
self-interested it's self-destructive
more than self-interested pretty uh
pretty decent chance inism gets recalled
Democrats could potentially keep the
seat if they urged their voters to
consolidate behind an alternative
Democrat but instead they're telling
them not to vote on The Replacements oh
dude Larry Elder for governor is going
to be so amazing that would be amazing I
want to see that in California yeah you
know because you've heard like what he's
gonna do when he keeps saying when he
becomes Governor is that he's just gonna
issue all these executive orders to like
just basically cancel out a lot of these
Democrat policies that have gone through
through these super majorities unchecked
that have basically bankrupted the whole
state caused so much homelessness uh
people can't afford to live you know I
mean and he's just going to put a stop
to all those policies in day one
according to him you know but we'll see
I think he'd do it
he would do it I don't know how
effective it would be yeah that's that's
the big risk right when when Trump got
into office he made the mistake of
thinking he could he could pull the
trigger and then we see clearly he was
obstructed every you know across the
board so it was a lot of work to be done
the the the the tendrils of the
corruption Run Deep and you you we have
a uh we have a um a medium-sized animal
trap for next to our chicken coop
because we you know we have a fox that
lurks around and we don't want him to
get in the chickens right so we set this
trap up well over time the the uh grass
and everything grew up into it and have
now locked it in place they grew all
around it now you just like rip it out
see that's what happens with the these
these super majorities this is what
happens in DC the swamp grows deep The
Roots get in there thick and then it's
really hard to pull it out so Larry
Elder could get in but you know is it
going to be able to effectively weed
another metaphor is like if you get
black mold toxicity if you breathe it in
what happens is the mold goes in your
system and then it diffuses evenly
throughout your entire system so you
just have small particles of mold in
your entire system it's really hard to
clean out similar of how politics can
corrupt and influence a society it's not
just something we can pull out it's
permeated the entire system it needs to
be purged slowly at the right medicine I
want to make sure I understand that so
are you calling Larry Alder the black
mold of white supremacy yes the black
mold and white supremacy okay all right
okay got it got it no you're saying the
corruption is infecting your body you
can't get it out the corruption is the
black mold of white that is good too
because like if it spreads around your
house you could scrub the room where you
see it but not realize there's tiny
particles already moved somewhere else
that grow again and it's like really
weeding it out my friends I have a white
white white pill means like optimism yes
yeah yeah optimism despite all
indications that drop optimism is crazy
yeah
Gandalf fighting the what was that that
demon that he fought on the bridge
he took the white pill I think that's
why he came back as the white wizard I
wonder if that's where the reference
stems from interesting no probably not
it's just because like dark and light
yeah Mexico which is funny because it
goes back to um just night and day the
during the day it's warm you're safe you
can see at night it's dark and the
Predators are lurking you can't see them
so humans Associated the two anyway
anyway I have good news for you
uh I think that it is likely we will see
Gavin Newsom uh be recalled and when
that happens Larry Elder is likely to
win and I have uh one bit of evidence to
back that kind of now this is definitive
proof you need only C on building up
suspense here once you see what I'm
about to show you everyone's probably
saying they're saying there's like I
don't believe it there's none of them
you once you see this you're gonna bet
you he won Larry other one
all right you guys ready yes yeah we
have this tweet from Gene Guerrero uh
she is a columnist for the LA Times she
said get ready for this one Democratic
Outreach to Latino voters on the
California recollection is not working
I've been speaking to Young latinxas and
almost none of them have any idea what's
going on this is really really bad
almost none of the ones I've spoken to
have any idea what's going on
um okay so let me let me break down for
you why I think this is a good news
if this lady from the LA Times goes to a
young Latino person and calls them a
latinx they're going to be like this
lady's crazy they probably have no idea
what she's talking about
we got we got some new uh staffers here
at the house and you know they don't
know who AOC is
they don't know who Brett Kavanaugh is
and I'm like those are good things
perfect you know I'm not trying to tell
you who they are we're just talking
about you know the state of politics and
they're like we don't we don't know my
great great do your job your
everything's great you don't got to
worry about these people regular people
don't know what latinx is and so this
shows you something powerful the
Democratic establishment is absolutely
psychotic there are people in the LA
Times going like the latinxas aren't
voting for us and the people are like I
don't know what that is so if they're
gonna start making phone calls I'm
looking for to speak with the are you
latinx latinx
is latinx that's just like that's the
hardcore in me I don't know but you know
like because the S at the end like
latinx oh it's latinx s yeah and that's
at the end Latin X's latinxas latinxas
it can't be latinxas
imagine someone you know calling you for
other people who are out there who like
who are like I'm sure the people who
watch this show they've heard these
words before but imagine your mom or
your grandma like the Latino and they
get a call and like hi are you all the
tinks the Teen X they're gonna be like
what is that that means why it's a
genderless someone of Latin it's so
insane how would you do that in French
oh they haven't got that far yet they
don't have to worry about the French
voters just wait just wait French voters
well there's northern Maine okay the
northernmost point of Maine is French
French American then you've got the
nawlins
how are you gonna how are you gonna get
how do you how do you degender French
you could say la l-e-a le Lex so it's
like a cross between LA and La no it's
just licks LX the x is silent so it's
lit yeah
yeah
we are silly people all the romance
languages are gendered right they're all
gendered right yeah yeah Italian yeah
yeah Spanish and French for sure
Portuguese German it's German but yeah
yes these people don't think that's true
they didn't think this is but think
about this this means that the
Democratic establishment is isolated in
this bubble where regular people are not
and although regular people that you
know default liberals will vote Democrat
they're not looking at this the same way
the establishment is so when the LA
Times comes out and screams Larry Elder
is the black face of white supremacy
regular people go
who I'm still saying that tell me about
this guy hopefully I'll meet him soon or
get to talk to him yeah yeah he's great
is he cool I should look into it though
I haven't said much about it because
he's really sharp yeah he he actually
had a a TV program that he did a few
times a week at the epoch times so I'm
pretty familiar with him because you
know I saw him a couple times and you
know I'm I've watched this stuff and
he's very big on uh Thomas Soul you know
the uh The Economist he I think he was a
mentor to him he's very big on um
instead of pointing at something like
systemic racism for our problems in the
back in the black community he'll point
out the fact that you know a large
portion of black community doesn't have
fathers in the home you know so he has
some traditional conservative values but
at least they're sane you know I mean
he's not out there you know saying
latinx is like
like drunk Dr Seuss you know I mean he
actually says things that that are
grounded and are reasonable even if you
disagree with him you know but no I I
Larry Elder would make a really
interesting addition to the California
government I I think aside from that
um
getting a change in California yes yes
just just for once it's like
um you know I'll put it this way
California is like if someone took it to
you know kept using a toilet without
Flushing and it's just a mess yeah and
Larry Elder will will be the flush yeah
you know what I mean like he's going to
be the person to come in and then just
take his foot up and then pull the lever
down and finally just he might find he's
the guy that needs the shovel and needs
to shovel all the poop out so that
there's enough room for it to flush
totally oh this reminds me though that
uh this this video did not get nearly
enough coverage Gavin do some cleaning
up at Berkeley
yeah oh man that was great he looked
like the petulant 12 year old kid that's
having to help his grandpa like clear
out lumber he's like pitching and he's
got this awful like you know face on him
it's so funny so that's that's how he
cleans up California petulantly and
angry like an elitist but Larry Elder
would actually come in and do some
serious work I think that's that's what
I'm saying about these people who just
want Power they don't want to do work
right they don't want to you gavinism's
like he was probably sitting in his
office and they were like okay Gavin
look this recall is a big deal there's a
lot of people who want to vote you out
we need to do something to show the
public you're there for them and he's
like I could give a speech and they're
like no no you got to get your hands
dirty
excuse me excuse me I'm thinking why
don't we go clean up
I thought for a minute you said you want
me to go clean up their mess we gotta
connect with people I won't do it and
then like some guy was saying Gavin you
gotta do it or you're done he's like ah
fine and he's like Ah that's how I
imagine it yeah and then he shows up and
he's like you make me clean that's
exactly that's the total Vibe he was
giving off in that video and it I don't
even think it had sound but you could
just see it on his face he was just like
why am I doing this this is beneath me
but think about it's like you know there
are people who work hard every day
construction and labor and and you know
medical professionals this guy what does
he do
he just he
California is just awful like where were
you and you were in Orange County yeah
Orange in Orange County but prior to
that I was in uh the uh the San Fernando
Valley in la oh okay okay yeah uh and
and that that's that's got a lot of
problems too still not as bad as San
Francisco with the homelessness and the
poop patrols and stuff uh no I mean it's
it's still got problems I mean
homelessness is a serious problem I mean
I'll I'll never forget I was standing on
my patio uh this is probably six months
ago and this is when they were releasing
prisoners from The Prisoner you know and
I saw two police cars pull up they
released a prisoner he signed his papers
at the bus stop and then we locked eyes
and I went back inside huh wow like yeah
it was because of the covet stuff yeah
I'm assuming I mean maybe it was just
like a standard drop-off but it was at
the same time that I was hearing oh
we're still releasing prisoners you know
and drives so uh yeah I mean it's
California has problems it's Statewide
it's not necessarily uh you know pockets
this is crazy to see this latinx
assistant yeah
no because I'm like I gotta be honest
like I was talking about when we were
mentioning mentioning this with Joe
Biden that even though I know Joe Biden
isn't with it like it's fairly obvious I
still believe there was some control you
know I'm like oh Joe Biden's out of it
but the system is in is is working right
I like it's maybe maybe in a weakened
state but it's still there now with
Afghanistan I'm just like there's no
system there is no president there is it
is just it is just absolute cast I look
at this thing with the Democrats and I'm
like there's no plan these people have
genuinely gone insane as much as I rag
on them I always kind of felt like the
wellness was was planned coordinated
like they knew what they were doing to
manipulate lie cheat and steal this
woman shows you they don't they've
they've eaten their own refuse
that that toilet's full they're eating
out of it they believe the crap they're
put they're filling up in these toilets
I guess it's a good thing though right
I don't know well it means like regular
people aren't in that world
that's a good thing but that I guess
I'll put it this way
people keep voting for it because they
think Republicans are bad
oh well you know Republicans are kind of
bad the two-party system is yeah
stripping people of their of their
choice
whether they realize it or not people
feeling like the lesser of two evils man
that drives me crazy that phrase lesser
of two evils I've heard it for like 20
years people want to vote for the lesser
of two yeah we're not even there anymore
now it's like you can vote for nothing
or for a toilet full of of crap huh the
Democratic party is like a piling up a
toilet and the Republicans are not going
to flush it so it's like you can vote
for the guys who at least won't stack up
on it or you can vote for the guys who
are going to stack up on it it's like
that's what we get what do you do like I
can't take a 78 year old and a seven
Dave you've read my mind that's exactly
what I was going to say I mean because
he he analyzed the situation pretty
thoroughly not too long ago he was
talking about how you know we're looking
at a very strong possibility in 2024
where it's Kamala Harris versus Donald
Trump and he's like if this plays out
it's a very interesting opportunity for
a third party candidate not going to say
me but you know but that that was his
point I really think that might be the
case I mean I'd like to think that would
happen but I mean won't they just uh we
can we can manifest it right Ian we have
a lot of power we can do it just by
thinking and meditating or talking about
it on TV like every I love calling this
TV by the way television
um yeah let's use the CR but I think if
we the more we talk about it like it has
compounding effects we can definitely
help manifest
I think uh
man it's tough because Trump's I I I
don't think Trump man Trump's tough
because his Character defects are an
issue but his policy you know what he
wanted to do was pretty good
like a second term agenda I like school
choice was big uh Banning critical race
theory in contracts it's a violation of
Lonnie way do it getting our troops out
of the Middle East and things like that
uh I'm for getting our manufacturing
back you know uh I'm for it protecting
our borders I'm for it
but Trump's character plays an issue now
I've never felt that his character was
like the guy could say the stupidest
things in the world if he's doing a good
job then fine you know who would you
rather have a plumber who can't you know
you got two plumbers one guy's falling
asleep and can't speak straight the
other guy's cussing like a sailor but
man he can fix on pipes you know which
one do you hire
2024
if we get maybe a third party option I
might consider it yeah well the thing
that worries me about Trump though is
that we saw it's not just like he was
the plumber that was swearing up and
down and was able to actually fix the
problem people like the machine got in
his way and prevented him from fixing
the problem right you know so I mean
isn't that just going to happen again is
it going to be you know russiagate 2.0
and I mean how strong is this machine
that's going to prevent him from
actually ins in uh instigating these
policies that he wants to do yeah that's
why I've been saying like DeSantis is
probably better than Trump because Trump
is one of the most polarizing candidates
we've ever had right and DeSantis will
get smeared like they're doing it to
Larry Elder but they're not going to be
able to smear him nearly as much as they
did with Trump because Trump had had uh
prominent personality in clips and
people ate it up DeSantis doesn't have
the the history of Donald Trump speaking
or anything like this they're gonna
they're probably already working on you
know they're doing Apple research like
crazy right now now the thing about Dave
Smith because you know we had him on
last Friday and we're big fans uh
Michael Mouse press secretary yeah
that's all I want to say that's all I
want to say it would you know what man I
can laugh about it
but I genuinely think America needs a
Michael Mouse prosecutor you know what
that leads to Michael Mouse vice
presidency
was he born in the U.S I think he wasn't
so he can't be president
if he's press secretary he's not going
to be vice president no no eventually
he'll just get his feet wet he'll learn
the system and then in 2032 I don't
think he can be I don't know Michael I
want to see how you deal with the Press
that's all I want to say I mean I think
you said the other night that he would
just run circles around these people
understatement exactly exactly they
would be sitting there they're like
their heads would start spinning and
then just like it would be like the
final scene in King's Men while their
head blow up yeah yeah that would be uh
that would be amazing but imagine what
the American people would finally hear
if you got
someone like Michael to to you know to
be saying to be speaking that's almost
more important in my opinion than the
presidency itself
because we don't hear from Joe Biden
every day we hear from genteki we didn't
hear from Trump every day we heard from
you know Spicer or or Kaylee and uh uh
they did a pretty good job
um Kelly mcenany was fantastic when she
pulled up the book and she like let me
fact check you journal and she had all
the Articles to fact check them
brilliant the thing about Michael though
is
he would add a level of
mockery yes and disdain and derision
that would be unparalleled a level of
malice if you will
exactly exactly built right into the
name that's a beautiful thing yeah
well one can hope I suppose we can
manifest it I'll put it this way I'm my
my biggest fear always with these things
is that people are going to be like a
third party can never win so just
support the Republicans and I'm like
well that's why they'll never win
because you won't put your faith in that
system you won't stand up for what you
truly believe in and and want and so we
don't know what's going on with any with
the libertarian party we don't know
what's going on the Republican Party one
of the challenges is that
there's no good party the Democrats are
insane if you give them power they will
use it they will misappropriate it even
if you find one like all these moderate
Democrats who are like we're gonna get
back to kitchen table issues vote for me
and then people said okay and they're
like here Pelosi here's here's power yep
okay so great you basically just voted
for Pelosi what's the point of that then
you get the Republicans and what do you
get when you vote Republican they do
nothing nothing is better than burning
the system down I guess so if that's
your choice and then you have the
libertarian party
which is insane yeah they're just
they're just insane yeah what the
libertarian party of Texas tweeted you
can't be pro-freedom and
anti-immigration and I'm like that just
doesn't even mean anything you said
nothing I'm not saying it's wrong I'm
saying it's not saying it work it's like
you can't like pizza if you're a fan of
carrots what what are you talking about
attitude yeah the argument that you
can't have secure Borders or Community
makes literally no sense it's like
you're either an anarchist or you're
you're a Nazi no uh there's varying
degrees in between those two things my
friend you can be very pro-freedom but
not an anarchist libertarian party does
not mean Anarchist it means there's some
government are those restrictions
anti-freedom it's just meaningless
garbage it doesn't mean anything and I
feel like most people who are starting
to pay attention to politics are like
can we just have like a guy to you know
do some maintenance on the machine you
know someone in government is going to
be like well we'll get everything going
the other thing too is we're always
writing up new laws we're always
complaining about things have we ever
stopped to consider that like it's
pretty going pretty pretty well let's
you know let's let's take a breather
how about for once we just kind of like
have a seat
just breathing it out a little bit no
it's always get someone in new laws more
more laws on the book stack them up
stack them up stack them they never go
away
have we always have to consider that
like you know it's going pretty well
I I I do but no not really never I would
love to see that to see more uh what's
the what's the revelation of uh long
yeah I guess the I guess the issue
though is there are certainly things
that I think need to change section 230
for instance
censorship stuff
you know so there's always there's
always something happening I guess the
bigger concern now however is going to
be the rise of authoritarianism I don't
know if you guys saw what's going on in
Australia we can talk a little bit about
that jeez yeah there's this viral video
where this dude is is covered positive
and he left his apartment so they should
have worn for his arrest
they play a clip of my they play a clip
of him on TV coughing and sneezing on an
elevator and they're like he just won't
do the right thing and I'm like it'll be
fair if you're sick and then you get an
elevator start coughing and sneezing out
covering your mouth it's kind of a dick
move yeah but like to issue a warrant
for his arrest now they're saying they
have to put signs on your you have to
put a sign on your door if you're
suspected of having covet suspected of
having covid they force you to lock down
and quarantine your house and they put a
sign in your door saying do not come in
leave packages at the door like they
gone full Nazi man
yeah yeah I heard they had like four
cases or four deaths out of 25 million
people I think is their total number of
people who live there four is simply not
enough to lock down your entire
population well I don't know if it's
four but I don't think any number is is
enough to lock down your entire
population I think we all agreed the 15
days to slow the spread and Dave Smith
said it best when he was like there's
nothing more permanent than a temporary
government solution yes our temporary
government program it's like yup you
guys ready for this one oh boy from The
Daily Mail get vaccinated or stay in
jail New York judges order defendants to
get coveted 19 shots as part of plea
deals and bail agreements but is it even
legal
a New York judge ordered a defendant to
get the covid-19 vaccine as part of his
plea deal while another made it part of
a drug dealing suspect's bail terms
Manhattan judge Judd rakoff granted the
release of a woman accused of drug
dealing on the condition she get
vaccinated another order came from Bronx
judge Jeffrey Zimmerman who made
vaccination part of a plea deal
neither defendant appeared to object I
mean to be honest it's probably like
okay I get to go and you know that's all
I got to do the problem I have with this
is the setting the precedent of
government mandated medication which we
already have with like fluoridation and
water and things like that it should be
between you and your doctor
should go talk to your doctor not have a
judge tell you what you should or
shouldn't do right or you know we have
Joe Biden now check this out
Joe Biden is calling on corporations he
tells companies to start mandating
vaccines and speech celebrating the
approval of the Pfizer vaccine hey
that's great the FDA approved Pfizer
vaccine wonderful now as same as it's
always been you can go talk to your
Healthcare professional that you know
and trust and figure out what makes
sense for you and don't ask me for
medical advice but to tell all of the
companies start mandating this we are
going to see a purge of sick people and
then what they go on unemployment
someone brought this up to me uh earlier
they said have you considered that with
New York mandating the vaccine with no
medical exemptions uh and now for
teachers as well and this this push from
big companies they're going to take all
of the people with medical conditions
that are still able to work and make
them unable to work and now they'll be
stuck on government benefits once again
just decimating the economy hmm
what do you think is Behind These
mandates I mean really because are we to
believe that you know uh Joe Biden's
saying that private companies have to do
this and judges saying that people have
to do this on conditions of their parole
are we to believe that this is the
result of a genuine concern for public
health or is there something I
definitely don't think so so what is it
what is it is it just is it just power
that's it I don't know man look at that
uh uh Newsome you know he doesn't want
to do work
imagine being able to just like tell
everyone to do what they're told and
they do it I think it's ideology you
know so
um
it's just man if people want Power you
know it's like you're playing video game
you put in a cheat code hmm it's fun
right and you're playing doom and you
type iddqd and then also you can just go
around doing whatever you want and it
gets boring kind of quick but that's
basically what they're doing they're
like oh now I can just snap my fingers
and it's done but these people are not
smart people
you know yeah like imagine you hired a
guy to fix your toilet and he's a
computer programmer but you gave him
carte blanche and you come in your
bathroom and just just spraying water
everywhere nothing makes sense and he's
like I I you leave it to me I'll figure
it out it's like
oh dude yeah will you though will you
really
but you know what we we're out in the
middle of nowhere now that's why I don't
know if I care you know what I mean like
you've been saying that for a while it's
just like these cities want to burn
themselves down let them do it you know
I mean
if people aren't going to vote to recall
Gavin Newsom then well there you go you
time to move right you know this is what
I'm saying people people were
complaining because I was because I'm
saying it out of cities and they're like
no you got to stay and fight and I'm
like listen
in New York City staying and fighting
was Voting and saying no to this and
then they keep electing Democrats they
elect Joe Biden you did and they ref and
their and and if people didn't stand up
in enough numbers to actually make that
change then
you you did it you you made your attempt
and now it's time to go I mean I suppose
you can try and stay but my point is
like if there's a bunch of people
yelling like Hey we're gonna win if we
all stick together and then when it
comes down to it not enough people stick
together
you tried what more can you do
well there was that one restaurant tour
in New York I think he had a bakery and
he said that he's not gonna you know he
had to he put this big poster in his
window saying we don't discriminate
based on gender sex anything vaccinated
unvaccinated and they they put that
poster up right after
um uh it was a de Blasio right after de
Blasio announced and they thought that
they would have like a lot of other
restaurants fall in line with them you
know and and say the same thing it's
just like we're not going to do this
nobody did so now they're just you know
the only ones out there saying we're not
going to follow this policy and we're
probably gonna get charged thousands of
dollars in fines so even when you do
step up and do that you're not
necessarily guaranteed to have other
people have that brave
you shouldn't worry about what other
people are going to do in a certain to a
certain extent sure you should stand up
for what you believe in and if that
means in the end they'll uh delete your
restaurant it's worth it
it's worth it to me because we see
what's happening with these kids right
you see that video in Australia where
the 12 year olds are getting pepper
sprayed and arrested yeah they're you
know there's a bunch of videos that are
like this of kids being arrested there's
a video out of Australia where it's a
bunch of teenagers partying like on the
beach and they get arrested and they get
fined a thousand bucks and it's like
to everybody who said to me oh I can't
speak up and risk my job because I have
to feed my kids and I'll be like okay
well you know good luck feeding them
when you're in a gulag because if you
don't speak up now hey it may be harder
right now but it's going to get way way
worse I mean we're looking at the signs
man look at what's going on with
Australia they're building quarantine
camps they're putting signs on people's
houses labeling them as you know unfit
undesirables this same course this the
same history has happened over and over
and over again it's almost like you can
just track it to a Beat you know here we
are in 2022
. what was going on in the 20s leading
up in the 30s into the 40s
you know people just go along with it
like your friend who was like cheering
for the fascism right right yeah yeah
totally fine with them but you know I
don't know enough about Australia or
Australian history to understand why
that place is the one that's actually
doing the full-on Nazi lockdown they
gave up all their guns
that was that oh that's that's what
happened in Australia so uh what do you
guys know when Australia give up all
their guns they gave up all their guns a
little while ago and not that I think
people would go out and actually fight
with their government
the left tries to use as an argument
because they always want to jump to most
extreme
if I say hey uh you know one of the
first things Nazis Nazis did was Target
disabled people making it harder for
them to live discriminating against them
then people will go yeah but the Nazis
also did most extreme thing ever and I'm
like yes that was bad that was really
bad one of the worst things in history
and they also did a bunch of other bad
things before that that led up to the
point where people accepted it it's
actually what Gina Carano was saying
remember that post Gmail they got her in
trouble she was saying that they they
demonized people to the point where
neighbor attacked neighbor and we've got
to resist that
they they took her job because of it yep
so we're walking into the exact same
thing it's it's one step at a time it's
not like you know that's what I always
say did you think the despots wouldn't
have an excuse
they're not just going to snap their
fingers and become authoritarians
overnight it looks like it was a 1996
there was a mass shooting in uh
Australia and they restricted guns so
here's here's what happens when you have
guns the government the the Agents of
the state are scared to kick your door
in without a warrant huh because you are
legally allowed to defend yourself
Brianna Taylor's boyfriend when they
when the police broke the door down
they fired at him he fired back and hit
a car I think he fired first and hit him
in the leg they tried charging him with
it and he ultimately won and in the case
there was no charge as in the end
because he was legally allowed to defend
himself from someone breaking his door
down
in Australia New Zealand Canada and the
UK we got these videos of cops walking
in Breaking the door down and just
coming in and beating people and
dragging him out
we don't see that in the United States
because the police are concerned the
citizen is probably armed it's not that
the citizen is going to get in a
gunfight no we don't want it to happen
it's that if they don't do it properly
the Power Balance between the individual
in the state are uh at that moment the
same
in the UK the state always has the
advantage so don't give it to them why
why give the state the advantage that's
a big difference so I don't know you
know Australia uh
people just slowly give up more and more
their freedoms and while you weren't
looking Nazis took over
um
so by allowing the government to take
their guns the government
just innately realized oh well now
what's the next step because it's it's
like you said it's not necessarily that
they were gonna you know use their guns
and arm in the streets and you know uh
it doesn't need to be intentional right
right it doesn't need to be intentional
it needs to just be that uh
water flows you know if you have uh
a river and there's a dam
and you open the dam the water pushes
through there's no conspiracy among the
water to make the water flow through
it's just the natural flow of things so
when you have governments that overreact
in our panicky and don't like an armed
citizenry
then you lose your guns what happens
when you have a population with no
weapons tyrannical government easily
just flows through those open Gates
so you know a lot of people I think
assume that the quest to take guns away
is on purpose I don't necessarily think
so I think some for some people Season
Guns is on purpose but I was watch I
watched this old like gun debate thing
with Rosie O'Donnell and Tom uh Tom
Selleck and I've watched a bunch of
other arguments about the 90s Solomon's
band stuff like that
it's panic
it's it's people who don't know anything
about guns panicking and then virtue
signal virtue signaling their way into
Banning them
and then what happens when you have a
disarmed population
tyranny flows right through those open
Gates
whether whether anyone wanted to happen
or not
look I don't know I don't know what you
think what you guys think about the uh
mandates and stuff I think if people
want to go get the vaccine it's their
business I just think excluding people
you know based on this stuff is
mandates are awesome in the right
circumstance I think this is the not the
right circumstance personally
um it's very exhausting to talk about
this stuff because I don't know if
screaming at a camera is enough to get
people to to to change but other than
that what else is there I don't know you
know self self-improvement that's kind
of the route I'm going in my life right
now
get better at singing get better at
thinking get better at typing the uh the
the vaccine minutes they're doing say
that you have to have for like you know
the military is doing it now too you
have to have the you know your vaccines
have to be up to date so I was uh
actually this is really really funny
somebody I tweeted vaxxer ID is racist
you see the joke I'm making voter ID is
racist you know facts already and then
what happened was was uh actually kind
of surprising
the responses I got from Democrats said
a vaccine card is not an ID and I was
like what what are they talking about
I'm talking about de Blasio requiring
IDs to get into buildings I didn't say
vaccine cards had vexer ID like they're
using the vaccine the the the vaccine
mandate as a way to mandate
identification they didn't know it and
then when I actually told some people
like the Mandate requires ID this one
guy was like no it doesn't and I was
like did you read the Mandate and he
goes yes and I was like then you didn't
read it and so he was like show me where
it says that I sent him the link
and then he comes back 10 minutes later
and he's like oh wow I didn't see that
part where it says an ID must be
government you know issued or whatever
and I'm like yes I'm talking about IDs
they don't know God that could be a
mantra of the 49 of that first poll you
mentioned oh I didn't see that part it
had to be like their Mantra you know
they they Revel in being nasty people
they're it's it's like all of the hate
float in One Direction it's the craziest
thing yeah I see the nastiness component
but at the same time I also see just
kind of they they feel some sort of
bizarre warmth and ignorance you know
they need things to be like third grade
level you know the people that I talk to
that just don't really see what's
happening or they perceive it in some
way that I just I don't understand they
they want they just want to tune into
CNN for 20 minutes have their 20 minutes
and then have their talking points and
be done with it they needed to be very
simple very easy and then they get on
with their lives and shout down people
that disagree with them
you know
I think we're addicted to convenience I
think the fake news is very much a form
of convenience and almost a form of
comfort to some of these people which is
really turning out to be quite the
problem because they're believing
everything they tell them so that if
they do change the rhetor can be like oh
Joe Biden did this thing wrong they're
just going to believe that Hook Line and
Sinker too so they're clearly not like
progress progressively thinking through
this what I was hoping when I started to
see this was that they were starting to
see that hiring someone based on the
color of their skin like they did with
Kamal was a terrible idea and voting for
someone like Biden against Trump
terrible idea but no it's just because
they're blindly following along the
media it makes them feel good but why
did it become so nasty you know like we
talked about Phil to Phil DeFranco
before there's a few other people I know
that I'm just surprised to see become
really vile people Petty tyrants um a
lot of it is perception like the way
that you see someone else's text is not
necessarily the way they intended it to
be seen and so you get people that are
angry they type something down out of
Rage which is Never Gonna totally you
know translate what they're feeling and
then someone else reads it and has their
own feelings that they put on top of
that just a massive miscommunication
like you said you talk to your friend
but it was through text and so a lot of
miscommunication through text I've had a
really good friend of mine I basically
cut ties with via text because I
couldn't handle the text comments after
a while like it's but but I still think
you you know I get it but you're missing
the main point like why is why are
people that I know posting
the meanest craziest things on Facebook
in general like people who used to be
normal people I know from Chicago all of
a sudden are posting things on Facebook
saying like f these stupid mfrs I hope
they all die and burn and suffer and I'm
like what the happen to these people
yeah yo like there's one viral tweet
where someone's like I've seen a whole
bunch of pro-vax people celebrating the
deaths of of people who would get
vaccinated from covet and wishing their
death but I've never seen the anti-backs
people wishing the same for those who
are pro-vaccine like what is what
happened to these people man it's like
they're they're infected with some kind
of rage and they just want more they're
addicted to rage and anger and being
mean people hmm
someone with a perhaps a bit of a
spiritual or religious Outlook would say
that there's some sort of possession
that's happening because people are I
mean people are really there a lot of
them I know exactly the kind of people
you're talking about and they're not
themselves and I don't know what that is
but getting to the kernel of where that
started that's really hard to unwind I
don't know I don't know what that is
demonic possession got it we'll roll
with that one yeah absolutely for
yourself what would put you in that
state of mind
like being really mean to people yeah I
just tried not to do that I think if I
was physically uncomfortable like it may
be overweight or eating I know when I'm
physically younger even if I eat crap
and then like a day or two days later I
just have a terrible
terrible mood so that I
I don't I can't understand it man I
could not understand posting F all the
mfrs I want them to die I post silly
silly not I tweeted out on I tweeted out
Joe Biden is the greatest president of
this or any generation then I waited a
few minutes for people to laugh and then
I said why aren't you retweeting this
like I got I got I got uh I got no hate
I got concerned you know I got empathy
and I have disdain I don't hate maybe
I'll cause pain it's like um residual
from Trump come in and be like the far
leftists all these jerks and Hillary's
like basket of deplorables and then
Biden comes in and he like arrests all
these people on one six and what he
should be doing is letting those people
go and commuting their sentences or
their their crimes like John Hancock did
with Shay's Rebellion when the farmers
revolted before they signed the
Declaration he realized they did it out
of desperation they didn't do it because
they were evil people so he pardoned a
bunch of them Biden should pardon those
people if he wants social cohesion right
now but as long as there's this quiche
said she said they're villains he's an
enemy it's gonna we're gonna see it in
the in the pocket yeah but dude there is
an objective reality here what is that
in Portland a bunch of right-wing groups
wanted to have a Summer of Love event
and sure you can argue they know what's
going to happen if they have an event in
Portland but there are allowed to put on
a rally where they talk and say things
antifa showed up and started throwing
gas and attacking people and then a
bunch of proud boys reacted and started
fighting back and then the media blames
the far right
certainly I think the far you know uh
the right-wing groups that are down
there don't understand that they're
being baited but it's like what am I
supposed to say right wing group is
allowed to have a rally they're allowed
to stand up on their their truck with a
big sign saying Summer of Love and the
hate
and that's okay if you don't like it you
know walk away antifa has no right to
show up and throw bricks at people and
beat them and crash you know try and
ramble with cars there was a shootout
and I think the guy who got a wrestle
was an antifa guy I don't know for sure
but he looks more like an antifa guy who
was shooting two people were shooting we
see a bunch of videos uh a bunch of Rave
reports of the interview people with
weapons and things like that the
objective reality is the media will call
anti-fault left wing and they'll call
conservatives far right and I started
thinking about this I'm like then what's
right wing
like if if if if you're a conservative
and then you're far right then how would
the media Define right wing oh I think I
know a uh pro-universal Healthcare
liberal like myself
traditional liberal I suppose more
classical liberal in a sense but they'll
call me right wing
they'll call an actual conservative far
right they've lost the plot yeah I don't
know what's left and right and
conservative and liberal like we look at
crypto economics and
being conservative would be to maintain
the current system of of fiscality you
know economics but we we see that it's a
broken system that's on a runaway train
to demise so it's actually conservative
to change that system to a more
conservative Financial system so whereas
you would think it's liberal to tear
down the economic order and up up
install a new system it's actually very
conservative to do that because the
system is dangerous
meaningless yeah yeah you can be a
liberal conservative that's far right
and far left at the same time it's okay
I'll tell you what's fun and a Centrist
when I was watching I was watching one
of Hassan's video because we talked
about Hassan Piper buying the big house
and he was talking about he said a lot
of things about Afghanistan that are
identical to exactly what I said that
it's a shame it's going down this way
it's good that we're getting out and
then he said but it's literally Trump's
fault this is you know this is Trump's
plan Trump negotiated this and my take
was and it's literally Biden's fault
Biden changed the plan Biden you know
failed like pulled you pulled our troops
out of Bagram Air Force Base in the
middle of the night
and I'm like if if someone someone super
chatted this to us if we had
um
You Know Jack masovic or Jack Murphy or
Steve Bannon sitting down with like vosh
or or Hassan they'd probably agree on
most things and then disagree on
cultural issues and culture War issues
and so it's like
I I guess I'm just pointing out
there's a tribal need in my opinion to
blame Donald Trump for everything and so
my criticism of a sign of this regard
and many in the left is it's literally
not Trump's fault if you actually follow
what's happened
but it's easy to say Trump negotiated
the withdrawal therefore he Bears
responsibility for how this went down
because there's
but Joe Biden is literally the president
and he changed the terms of the deal
so it's like it's tribalism yeah I want
to avoid trashing Biden like big problem
I was born in Ohio and Cleveland Browns
for Life Cleveland Browns fan because
that's my hometown and um when the
quarterback would screw up a Cleveland
Browns quarterback throw a few in in
completions throw an interception the
fans would turn on the guy and be like
this guy sucks he's terrible and then
the guy would start playing worse
because his morale would be shot and
then he'd be like he's terrible get rid
of him they'd go through a quarterback
get a new quarterback he's the The
Golden Child throws a few interceptions
he's terrible get rid of him so they
destroyed their own team by talking crap
about it if we do that with Biden I'm
afraid that could happen what if the
quarterback was 78 years old and
couldn't talk you still want to improve
his morale at that point you say get him
out get him out look I get what you're
saying if I was sitting there with you
Ian at a Cleveland Browns game and the
quarterback was 78 and he was going and
you were like don't don't rag on him man
we got to give him a chance I'll be like
bro come on dude what are you talking
about like but it's more subtle it makes
sense if he was 40 like at what point do
you watch a quarterback throw in
completions at what point do you say
he's not the guy anymore bro Joe Biden
wasn't the guy to begin with like he's
the commander hey chief take the listen
quarterback of the the best team in the
NFL let's try this what if the
quarterback was 78 couldn't talk right
and wasn't actually chosen by the by the
team's owners or managers it was just
that the quarterback they were gonna
have the fans didn't like so they were
like just get us anybody and they're
like we got this old guy he's sitting in
the stands just take them because the
fans don't like that guy so it's like
what you were saying right you got a
quarterback he throws a few you know
interceptions and he and then when
people boom he says cussing at him and
he's rude and they're like we don't want
to watch this game anymore and then the
owners like we're losing money what do
we do we need anybody anybody and
they're like just grab that 78 year old
guy who can't talk straight and now
you've got people sitting there watching
and they're like dude this guy can't
play
but what do we do and you're being
you're like dude we don't want to lose
another quarterback don't rag on him and
I'm like I think we want to lose this
quarterback I think he can go home now
but you lose the whole team when you but
the vice quarterback is even worse right
the second speaker speaker of the field
is just insanely bad so assuming you
don't have another option there's no
free agents waiting to get hired right
now then that's when morale Improvement
is key because like Tom Brady wasn't
necessarily the best quarterback but he
was in a great organization with massive
people were behind him he had incredible
morale and thought he was great so he
kept being great he kept fulfilling that
prophecy what would president Kamala be
like she'd laugh a lot
live laugh love maybe we get some video
of her firing a pistol could you imagine
could you imagine a president Kamala
like already she's laughing at the uh
the question about Americans trapped in
Afghanistan but could you imagine her
like sitting down with like Vladimir
Putin and he's like if you do not
withdraw your troops from Libya we'll
fire a nuke
wow are these troops in Afghanistan are
they like 15 000 Americans left for dead
or they just left are they going to be
in prison like prisoners of War well the
Taliban is saying like no no we'll get
the Americans out and and then there's
all these these afghanis and their
families that worked with the American
troops that are still there like I don't
know how many thousands tens of are
those people we're just going to leave
them to be incarcerated sold into
slavery have their heads cut off like I
mean here's here's the challenge
you gotta watch out for the propaganda
there's a bunch of propaganda coming out
saying like you know America don't do
this there's a like I saw one story it
said a Famous Afghan tick-tocker was
captured and executed by the Taliban and
it seems like a lot of these stories are
preying upon Western sensibilities to
make Americans be like we have to go
back in and save them all and it's like
no no
the reason the problem's this bad is
because we did this in the first place
you need to stop
to stop
unless you're Pro colonization I guess
you know and you think America should
colonize then it's like okay well then
well then you're Pro colonization
colonize Mars maybe yeah well they want
to colonize Afghanistan and then build a
pipeline
into Europe I'm not a big fan of
colonizing on top of other people yeah
so what do you do like I don't mean I
don't mean do competition I was like
what what do you do about the fact that
you've got International Elites and
you've got massive corporate interests
in getting oil pipelines out of
Afghanistan and they're going to fund
the politicians and the system will flow
in that direction
probably change the economics situation
I think you know remove the fiat
currency from diminish its value it
seems how do we get the left to be on
board with like ending the fed or about
or auditing it or something you got to
make it exciting uh my goal is to get
super famous with a hit song and that
people are like yeah whatever you say
because I'm obsessed with you I don't
know worship no maybe maybe what if we
accuse the FED of being racist yes there
you go that's a good start yeah I do
like that they've gotten woke yeah it's
like no problem no I don't like that
either
tactics against them yeah I'm not a big
fan no no they need now let's be honest
the Federal Reserve was created by a
bunch of rich white men to uphold white
supremacy there you go yeah you think
they buy the best no it's worth a try it
only works when they're when their
priests tell them you know when they're
right the cathedral they try the
Rockefeller Rothschild keyword thing in
like 2011 and that was like all the buzz
is like oh the Rothschilds oh the
Rockefellers and like those those
families were involved in like the
creation of the banking order and the
Federal Reserve and things like that but
so that shock value of like Rockefeller
is gone like that came out like 2008
that name all of a sudden was like ooh
the big bad name right
it's tough to say because like you know
this is something James Lindsay talks
about all the time when he's like you
know going through his like he's
analyzing Herbert Mark hughes's uh work
about you know the Marxist Professor
Herbert Mark Hughes who's kind of in a
sense an architect of the woke stuff is
that the asymmetry is the whole point
it's there's not really a reasonable
debate to have with some people that are
kind of infected with the woke ideology
it's about asymmetry it's about this
side is permitted this side is not
permitted plain and simple there's no
there's no room for discussion there's
no room for exchange it's just
right-wing bad that's not tolerated left
wing good all goes this is part of this
guy study anything Herbert Marcus yeah I
mean this is yeah this is uh his essay
is called repressive tolerance uh very
dense essay I would encourage you to
listen to James Lindsay's uh analysis of
it because he you know he's lived in
this world you know
um but but yeah that was essentially his
whole take on the idea is that um
tolerance at a certain point is
repressive and is bad so you can't be
tolerant of the right
you have to be tolerant of the left yeah
who is that other guy that
um
I remember his name the Paradox of
Tolerance
that's right oh yes yeah yeah I've heard
of that yeah and it's he's not wrong
right the problem is the left is
intolerant and we tolerate them yeah
yeah there you go well that's the other
thing you see coming through uh in our
current Society with with Marcus and his
ideas is he was saying that it's a
pretty interesting argument that he
makes he says you know if we had just
pre-censored Hitler and just said let's
not let him speak then we wouldn't have
had the Holocaust now would we so we
have to pre-censor these ideas they
can't be expressed because if we
tolerate those speeches then it's
repressive
uh Hitler yeah yeah he absolutely was he
was yes and the the people on the left
try to bring up saying like you know
like see even you know even they went
after him and then the counter is yes
and it didn't do anything because when
you push things into the corner or they
just fester in darkness and if people
are actively paying attention to to
these ideas then they understand them
and they can reject them but you let
these ideas grow in the darkness and
then it's all of a sudden you're like
standing up and like whoa where did all
this come from well that's what we're
seeing now is that there's that bad idea
the idea of pre-censorship is happening
again with big Tech platforms they're
saying let's just not let these ideas
out there and it's backfiring doesn't
work that way yeah yeah but uh I have to
say I I don't want to leave this before
we go to super Chats on a sad note I
want to point out that woman who called
uh uh young Latinos latinxas and just
remind you all that these people have no
idea how to communicate with young
people and they're probably going to
create a generation of more
liberty-minded individuals who are
anti-woke not a guarantee yes you know
they'll get a lot of you know people to
join their little cult tribalist
whatever but I think a lot of young
people are going to be like what'd you
call me like that has nothing to do with
my community yo like why is Fast and the
Furious so popular
family I just watched F9 oh how was it
sorry I like it I love fine dude the
Fast and the Furious Cinematic Universe
is the best oh my God you know why well
why because they're selfish they're
self-aware are they it's absolutely like
dude they went into space oh they went
to outer space
awesome why did they go to outer I don't
know no one no I don't I don't know and
and but it's self-aware and the point is
Fast and the Furious is like cars musics
music pretty girls and action adventure
because people like these things right
they don't know what this this woke
stuff doesn't
but no for real and fast nine I'm sorry
for the spoiler guys movie's still out
Bring It On they go to space just think
about how hilarious that is we're like
where the first movie was like a normal
crime drama yeah yeah and now they're in
space fast nine in outer space I was
watching it and I was just I'm laughing
I love it each and every movie is better
they did Hobbs and Shaw did you see that
one oh yeah yeah Fast and the Furious
Hobson Shaw it's a Superman in that
movie I don't even know what's going on
it's amazing dude they gotta roll with
it and and uh they I really hope that
eventually they get to the point where
they legit get super powers yeah oh
that'd be cool how amazing would it be
if the ffcu literally becomes a new
superhero Cinematic Universe yeah this
is great just because well they already
have super soldiers
so they have the passion for Captain
America right so in in Hobbs versus Shaw
you had AJ's Elba playing a guy who was
a super soldier so he was like super
strong he was great he's awesome yeah
movie I didn't like that movie but I
loved him in that movie I thought the
movie was fantastic I didn't like
Statham my problem with Statham is that
he never seems like that he's at risk
there's never any like sense of urgency
or danger he always is like two people
he's an actor he knows his character
can't be hurt so that there's no fear of
so I'm like every time he's on camera
I'm not afraid that the character is
gonna die it's just him waiting for it
to happen dude I I want to see in F10
like Vin Diesel like raids you know the
the super soldier compound and gets
injected and then he becomes he gets
superpowers you know and then uh
Ludacris is just he can fly for some
reason I think that's the only way you
can heighten it from here I know yeah
yeah that's right that's the logical you
go to Mars yeah is Justin Lin always the
director
he's the writer producer and director of
this F9 it just every every movie is
crazier than the last like to an extreme
degree I like that people love it they
make like they could totally start like
bending reality like Doctor Strange
I don't want to spoil the movie oh it's
great like we're so close to to Vin
Diesel getting super powers
a brother apparently he could have like
a second cousin who turns out to be like
his mom or something a wizard yeah there
you go yeah I like that well Vin
Diesel's a big like d d guy isn't he
yeah actually interesting he's a
hardcore game how could it be if like
they go to Egypt and find a Stargate
aliens
what's next man
already super soldiers all right all
right so we we don't want to jump too
much
so the next one's got to be like they
find the super soldier serum and they
themselves get the super soldier
abilities then the next one can be like
someone you know jumps really high yeah
you got to get Vin Diesel gotta get
bombarded with radiation sometimes and
use the whole scene of him being like
yeah his arms bulging
and then he turns green yeah
dude I already when I turned it on I
know it's going to be just like nonsense
yeah it's awesome nonsense it's just
like
it's man it's a parody of itself but
it's it's that's how you do it you got
to lean into it I love it all right
let's read let's read some super chats
okay all right smash that like button
subscribe uh share the show with your
friends and go to timcast.com be a
member we'll have a bonus segment coming
up for all y'all
we got Jonathan galterini says my wife
and I have been trying to have a second
baby for three years now nice we had to
resort to IVF which is way too much for
us to afford a GoFundMe shout out would
be dope Andrea and Zachary IVF
fundraising by Andrea Kunkel best of
luck for you on your children and
Endeavors try fasting too when you when
you free up the blood flow in your lower
core it helps uh you know free up the
blood flow in your genitals I've found
which can help you have babies all right
yeah Patrick Patrick Stover says Tim
what is the best guitar and why is it
the Telecaster oh you know I I honestly
uh I just like it the way it sounds to
be completely honest so my first guitar
was a strat and then uh the first guitar
given to me when I was a little kid was
a strat and then I got
um a strat acoustic when those came out
which is a small fiberglass body
Stratocaster it looks like a
Stratocaster Fender Stratocaster but
it's acoustic and it doesn't sound very
good they don't make them anymore is it
that black one yeah yeah it was the
first one I ever bought myself but then
I bought a Telecaster a white Telecaster
because it just sounds better it's the
easiest way to explain it I mean I
suppose you can always change out
pickups and customize and do whatever
you want but I just got we're building a
music studio production studio for all
the music and so we got the acoustic
Sonic Telecaster
incredible was that brown one yes nice
it's it's up there it's expensive but it
is I I they had a really expensive one
it was like four grand because it was
some exotic African wood or whatever and
I'm like we're not trying to you know do
like we want something that sounds
really really good so we can make music
and it's hard to justify an expense this
High even for the one I did get but for
the live performances I think this thing
is absolutely the sound is incredible it
gives you an acoustic sound or an
electric sound when you can just change
yeah it's brilliant uh and it's a
Telecaster it's the acoustic Telecaster
that's amazing amazing amazing I don't
know I just love it I I don't like
strats
um I like I like Schecter uh but I think
just telecasters man yeah I'm in love
the Martin the Earth it's the
Dreadnought I mean I'm just that's the
one I've played for 20 years it's the
acoustic Martin Dreadnought yeah
electrics I don't know I don't know much
about them I've had a Stratocaster that
was my first one yeah I think most
people get a strat to start you know
it's like a cheap black and white yeah
that's what I had
John R says this is in reference to
yesterday's cast Castle number one have
you ever had Irish cream and coffee Tim
you're in for a real treat I've not we
bought we bought Irish cream oh okay and
it's like it's actually creamy I'm like
oh maybe I'll try that in the coffee
yeah we went to the liquor store because
we're building the new studio and so we
wanted to get like good booze for guests
and for celebrations like we're not
gonna dish out really expensive stuff
for just literally no reason just waste
money or anything like that so I got
corn whiskey which was like 10 bucks and
that's I'm the most excited for that
because I want to get some of this the
snootiest whiskey snobs and be like
here's your corn whiskey with a plastic
bottle no it's in a glass bottle it's a
nice bottle
um but we got some good stuff too and a
lot of people are pointing out that none
of us drink everybody who went to liquor
store nobody drinks and so they're like
it's like bringing vegans to a butcher
shop like what are you doing we have
this
ohishi whiskey Tim we had a little bit
of this before the show the three of us
did and I'm gonna drink everybody tasted
it it's good you can tell it's made with
rice I like it yeah
it's not really bitter it's it's very
smooth yeah it's part of the experience
so that when people come we you have
your option between your caffeine or
your alcohol
so you know you can either some people
are really nervous you know you can give
them a little bit of a little bit a
little bit of boost if they're if
they're uh tired they're like tired we
got red bulls and for people who are
just crazy and listen to new metal or
whatever we just they mix it together
and then they die oh John R's got a
number two he says what's a good
raspberry vodka you ask there isn't one
huh and number three something weird
liquor wise that no one would expect you
to have have at a party absinthe let me
know before you go to the liquor store
again and I'll hook you up good stuff by
the way have you guys had it oh yeah I'm
pretty sure we got some it is really
good you could put an ice cube in it and
then light it on fire that's like one of
the um one of those what they call it a
traditional ways to do it cool burn your
little or maybe it's like a sugar cube
or something oh yeah that's what it is
yeah yeah yeah and it's got It's Made
with wormwood it's psycho mildly
psychoactive but I think that's the
stuff in Europe I don't think you can
get that here oh interesting yeah I
think this so I was talking to that he
said he's like oh do you want absinthe
and I was like is that is that legal
here and he's like it's really different
you go to Europe yeah that's a different
thing yeah so everybody buys it all
excited but you know it's not F yeah
all right let's see we got here
um
Andrew Kari says Biden is stopping extra
unemployment in early September just
after pushing for vaccine mandates no
coincidence
interesting interesting
all right balians has not Ian according
to Rachel Maddow the Afghanistan Fiasco
is all because of Trump's immigration
laws that hindered the Afghan people
from coming to the U.S of course of
course they couldn't get out
or they couldn't get in yeah what's the
phrasing here Michael Shipley says I
found a company that will customize
beanies let me know where to send the
info you wanna yes wdfo gmail.com
that'd be good I will accept that
cigars and SIG arms says I don't know
what's the most amazing phenomenon from
the last year right Wingers turning on
the cops or left wing left Wingers
simping for big Pharma great there you
go man um
funny huh John R says number four no I'm
not an alcoholic all right
James Nelson says never forget the
150-ish generals and Command Staff Obama
and Biden Purge to get this woke
military oh yeah
and Trump didn't do that Trump could
have come in and been like you're all
fired the one thing he was famous for
and he didn't do it enough
Sarah says a friend fought in
Afghanistan after withdrawal he's one of
only a handful of soldiers left from his
unit the rest passed in the last week
suicide support our veterans they need
and deserve it definitely man sorry to
hear it
herb derp says what's the most
heart-wrenching movie scene you've seen
someone showed me the choice scene from
Sophie's Choice today broke my heart
into a million pieces
I'm a big fan of that scene from The
Notebook
um Ryan Gosling I won't I'm going to
spoil it for you I've watched The
Notebook if you haven't seen that oh man
it was in um it was in fast eight you
know when I'm just kidding Sean very
emotional we were in the theater
together
now the notebook's Good Very uh very
emotional Pride man that was an
emotional time in my life but yeah I
think I cry every time during that final
scene so good when he finally breaks
through and gets to her oh God yeah
that's that's got wrenching
I'll have to watch it oh it's great so I
hear all right let's see Brian Ventura
says Tim hitting Chicago for the first
time this October keep up with the
foodie scene there still if so what's
the best neighborhood to find the
following Ramen pierogi's Deep Dish
Pizza PS love the website best ten
dollars ever hey thanks for being a
member at 10cast.com
um Ramen I don't know about Ramen in
Chicago do you have any I've never had
it in Chicago yeah pierogies well I
don't know if it still exists but in in
the Midway area where I grew up it's
like a very polish neighborhood and you
you can probably find a lot of little
Polish delis around there like it's like
Pulaski Avenue you know on the south
side but uh man I honestly don't know
deep dish pizza however you know
I like Lou Malnati's what do you think
Giordano's Lou Malnati's I'm gonna go
with Giordano's but we got it frozen and
had to cook them off and I think the um
it's not Illuminati's what do you call
it Lou Malnati Lou malnaties
I think because it was frozen it would
it would become a little watery so I
didn't get the full Lou Malnati's
experience I will tell you this when we
order Giordano's here we order deep dish
because we're like I'm like hey I'm from
Chicago I'm gonna make people try and
see what they like better when you cook
the Lou malnatis it's like it comes out
with water on top and I literally lift
it and drain the water off of it it's
not bad though it's like tomato juice
it's just like watery and I have no
problem with it I think it tastes better
but that's just like full disclosure the
Giordano's thing it tells you to
microwave it yeah it comes in Frozen
it's like micro then bake it and I'm
like uh
that's something's wrong there it is
still good though it is very very I'm a
huge fan of the art of pizza in Chicago
if you guys haven't had that yet the
deep dish art of pizza I used to go to a
place called Big Tony's which is just to
the west of um
Bucktown I think it's like it's like
it's like in Logan Square and I would
get the jardinera pizza and that was my
favorite like with the with the carrot
and celery and all the cauliflower and
pickled veggies giardner that's a
Chicago thing right yep yeah yeah yeah
that's good stuff yeah I remember when I
first went to New York I went to uh
sandwich shop like a bodega and I was
like I'll get you know let me get like a
roast beef and cheddar with some
giardinera and the guy was like with
what what and I was like jardinera and
he was like I don't know what you're
saying and I was like uh like like
jardinera and he's like bro I don't know
what that is and I went oh
I went to I went to Potbelly's and I saw
the bottles and they're called hot
peppers they don't say giardinera it's a
Chicago thing yeah it's like being a
different country it's like what do you
mean and then I remember the first time
I when I was buying a sandwich they had
no options it said hero and roll or
whatever and I was like the hell's a
hero you know like no no no hero h-e-r-o
is what a sandwich is called in New York
yeah it's called the hero yeah and so I
walk in and I'm like what's a hero and
he's like sandwich and I was like but
like what is it I don't know what it is
we call them Subs in Chicago yeah yeah
yeah or Hoagies yeah same as yeah I
guess I don't know anyone really says
Hoagie yeah I grew up with Hoagie in the
mountains yeah that's what we called
them yeah okay we said sub a long time
yeah yeah in Ohio there were subs and we
have Subway sub sandwiches excess Subs
what's the best food in Chicago hmm if I
was going to recommend food in Chicago
well we all love Portillos oh The
Stinking Rose that has some great garlic
bread I think that's downtown Chicago
well there you go Chicago singing Rose
uh go to
El Gallo on on Archer South Archer
Avenue get yourself a burrito burrito
that's where it used to go there's Los
Gallos and no no El Gallo I think is on
um 63rd Street near Narragansett and Los
Gallos is on Archer we used to go there
those people that was that was always so
much fun if it still exists I haven't
been there a long time
all right let's see we got here
well that one's a mean one I'm not gonna
read that one don't do it
total Wildlife Management says my son is
a new Marine they just told everyone if
you don't get the jab then you have to
be discharged
but isn't that true for everybody who
signs up you get tons of vaccines that's
my understanding yeah yeah I don't
understand this one
like when I I know a ton of people who
have joined and they're like yeah you go
through basically they give you a bunch
of vaccines and it's like okay well
here's another one I don't get it it's
FDA a non-approval thing and I I saw
they did approve the Pfizer vaccine but
then I I read something or someone sent
me something that said that it didn't it
didn't it was still had problems but
they just had approved it did you read
anything about that I did not I did not
see that I read that they that passed
the trials with an exorbitant amount of
people and that it's going into
long-term it's going into phase four now
which happens after FDA approval
which is like I look I can respect
people saying that they want to make
their own health choices I can respect
people saying that they they want
long-term you know studies and stuff but
I just think it's important to point out
some perspective
most people go to the doctor and get
prescribed medications they never look
into
and that should change people should
actually start looking into this stuff
definitely the information is available
on the internet I should yeah just if
that's your attitude now maintain it
across the board for your health and
make proper Health decisions I think
Mike cernovich had one of the best uh
responses to this it's a comic where
it's like a big fat woman in a rascal
saying like about the vaccine I don't
know what's in it or whatever and it's
like his point was you're not healthy
there's a lot of people who are like
well I don't want to risk my health it's
like dude you eat greasy cheeseburgers
and smoke cigarettes and get drunk
you're not like it's you're not what is
it you know you're not worried about
your health ideological in the in
instances like that it must be ideal
ideological right I mean there's
certainly something different from being
like I know that if I eat a cheeseburger
it'll make me fat if I eat too many and
like taking a medication but I just
think there's a lot of small things that
people should have some perspective on
and more importantly like regardless of
that people should you know eat better
exercise
we do what you got to do use that
inversion table you know yeah that one's
great
EOD Voodoo says first Super Chat Afghan
vet a haiku my children run in the yard
missing limbs hinder obstruct delay and
drain was it all worth it thank you Tim
Castine that's hardcore thank you
Logan Culver says where's the Kurt
schlichter episode from last week it is
on rumble.com if you go to rumble and
look up timcast IRL it is also on the
website if you go to the website it it
will be there
um you know there you go
Jared lifeguard says Ian what what would
you think would happen if we mastered
Fusion Energy and magnetic
Transportation what would the masses do
with that technology all the timcast
viewers have to find the time to read
Atlas Shrugged you could
um transport food across long distances
really fast by launching it into orbit
and then catching it as it comes back
down with a magnetic like counter pull
so shipping it could it could accelerate
shipping you could also people could
take trains from place to place and you
could have little Villages all over the
place as opposed to centralizing in in
cities so that would help the spreading
out issue I think
Connor H says how many ears does
Jean-Luc Picard have three his left ear
his right ear and the final front ear I
love that joke like Davy Crockett
all right all right all right
good uh humor
all right let's see
Katie says I'm not gonna donate a lot
because I don't have a lot of money but
I appreciate the work your whole team
does I love that you call both sides out
especially useless Republicans I wish
you all well thank you that's the
problem with the Republican party but
it's like useless isn't as bad as
destructive you know what I mean right
so it's like what am I supposed to do
I'm not going to come out and just lie I
guess
all right
purposeful porpoise says yo Tim prepare
yourself for the Stargate episode where
the general looks straight into the
camera and basically admits that the
show is a cover for a real Stargate
program aliens confirmed what oh come on
what what I don't know if the joke we
had from the from the jam session was
put in the Vlog
where we sang a song about Ian Ian's
Revenge it wasn't in the blog it wasn't
no it wasn't in the Vlog I wished it was
that was a good one yeah so we jammed a
song where I was basically it's like
about Ian killing a guy oh and but the
the chorus is about how he kills a guy
because it's his revenge but the verse
is me saying it's it's really true it's
not a joke you think it is because then
a YouTube video and we're just messing
around but it's real you know tell a
friend yeah it's all your friends I
should have said something like please
help me you know I'm stuck in a corner
he's gonna come after me
only playing the song is keeping him
occupied very good yeah uh but anyway
yeah about that fourth wall breaking
um I I must have missed that one what's
what season is that in the last season
oh it happened I thought they were
saying it's going to happen no now that
the show ended it along interesting yeah
yeah this is like a Maya Native American
thing is that Stargates are real they
would have these like areas that were
carved out that they would stand in and
when they were inside of them their
minds would transcend the universal
superstructure so it seemed and they
would like communicate with aliens and
see other realities
Mark s says love Larry Elder totally
voting for him on his reek on this
recall Ian Larry Elder is the guy that
put Dave Rubin on the spot and got Dave
to start thinking critically more
classically libertarian keep up the good
work you find people that's right uh
Dave was talking to Larry Elder and
mentioned I think he was talking about
systemic racism but Larry like clearly
knew a lot more than Dave on the issue
and then Dave was kind of just like
respectfully like oh okay but then
Larry's conversation with them kind of
opened up Dave to be like hey man you
got to like read the stuff and then Dave
was like okay and Dave like he posts the
video he's proud of it you know like
being the kind of guy who's going to
hear something and then change his mind
yeah it was like from five years ago
yeah yeah that's the one cool thanks for
letting me know about that good clip
great dude mm-hmm
yeah so Dragon lady said the same thing
Ian watch Dave rubin's first interview
of Larry Elder back in I think 2015.
awesome Reuben calls it one of his most
transformational moments wow very cool I
could see it nangmar says is Ian timcast
kessel's shaman uh yes I guess
technically by default easily yeah I'm
down to higher more Shaman though if you
want
Jesus Sanchez says I don't know how far
you are in Stargate you should watch
season 4 episode 16. I'll check it out
I've uh so
there's like three episodes that come on
per day so I'm in like season nine or
something right now but I've skipped
half the episodes in between because I
certainly can't watch three episodes a
day so it's like you know it's hard to
keep track you just skip through and
look for ones you like the premise no no
because it between like four and six
there's like you know four five and six
they play an episode of Stargate and I
can't watch every episode all the time
so I'll see like one of the three and
then you know so now they're already at
like the end of the show or whatever
that sucks amazing show though really
really good show
I'll have to look for the one where they
uh he looked at the camera
all right let's see we got here
Elizabeth Carmella Comedian says hey Tim
and gang the other weeks you shouted out
my son Orion blew his mind thank you we
live in northern Cali Solano County
specifically don't believe what you see
on the news we are voting Newsom out I'm
voting in person
all right perfect there you go let's see
it nice let's do it I'm feeling good
sketchum says PA trucker here I haven't
had work the past couple of days due to
no workers at warehouses to load or
unload trailers oh man it's coming it's
getting crazy it's not good
yeah Matt
Ram says do we trust the same people
that approve the medication that started
the opioid epidemic no Luke I puke I
bought nine chickens for our roosters
whoa that's too many roosters
Luke's coming back soon you know he's
coming back soon
um as for trusting people the issue with
the opioid epidemic was the was the um
not the FDA it was the pharmaceutical
companies and the doctors just like
dishing them out and they were like
encouraged to prescribe you know
medication weren't they something like
that I don't know the full story it was
like a big a big investigative piece on
it
um look I don't I'm not I'm not saying
I'm a big fan of the FDA and like
revolving door policies of like the head
of this pharmaceutical company it's a
job in the government or anything like
that but I think the opioid one is
like telling people like
to take a medication that turned out to
be extremely addictive and problematic
yeah they didn't frame them as addictive
that was a big part of the problem they
sold them to kids like little kids too
young kids oxycodone Oxycontin and then
kids were coming down with hardcore
addictions then they'd look for the next
biggest thing then all of a sudden
fentanyl gets developed oh man
probably as a result or frontals from
China
jeez dude yeah that's what's up
Kevin Pilgrim says Chris says he is bad
at speaking I absolutely love him as an
in-house guest great job Tim fam oh yeah
there you go thank you very much for
that thank you it's awesome
OMG puppy says you can buy lefe absinthe
that's legal now it definitely has a
mild cannabis like high in addition to
the alcohol I serve some at a party and
there were some strange Revelations like
a truth serum oh snap yes interesting
that was my experience with it too with
the wormwood wow great mild psycho
psychoactive so you get the THC kind of
wavy understanding along with the
alcoholic subdule
Jason lindelm says watched your cast
castle video of you all getting musical
equipment and gear jealous I want to jam
with you and everyone
there's a bunch of stuff with the music
it's um we license music for some of the
stuff we do there we want to make our
own we want to just generally produce
music I've got a bunch of songs I need
to produce but we're thinking like
in-house for all of the we've got what
like three new podcasts on the horizon
and we're gonna make our own music so
that we don't worry about licensing or
rights or copyright strikes or anything
like that and we want to have live shows
so we just need the equipment and the
production with the speaker systems we
got are so so we can do the live shows
outside and then we got one so we can do
live shows in the basement it's gonna be
a lot of fun I think Andreas got a song
in the featured in the Vlog yesterday I
think that was one of his all right I
couldn't tell you that sounds like his
style there you go I think so crazy
digital Helena art yeah
Helena oh see here we go Michael Adkins
says Fast and Furious should team up
with Transformers yes
guys would be able to stay away
all right
Tate story says hey Tim and crew 20 year
old guy and wanted to make a change and
joined the mises caucus of Utah also
you're wrong the Jazz Master is the best
guitar also if you're in the need of
another animator I would love to be of
use eventually yes at more animators I
tried the Jazz Master it was good so
they have the acoustasonics they're like
it I don't know how to describe it
they're not just Acoustics there are but
they're more like electrics I don't know
they're amazing
um they all sounded great they were all
really really amazing
the Jazz so I would say the Telecaster I
thought was kind of the best then the
Jazz master and then the strata uh the
the the the Stratocaster
close tie though I think the issue with
the Jazz master was that it did sound
really really good but I just am
impartial to the Telecaster I guess so
maybe that's a fair maybe that is true
to say the Jazz Master is is better
um I think it's just personal preference
at that point but I was really impressed
with the Jazz Master to be completely
honest I was like wow
Sean Anderson says Fast and Furious 1 is
Point Break with cars and I love it
that's right Point Break great movie
Aiden says will you guys have Charles uh
hiskinson on as a guest cardano has
exploded recently yeah we've been
meaning to do that hoskinson yeah
hoskinson oh yeah right he just needs to
reach out to me cardano has a bright
future I don't know I still have not
been reading a lot about it the last
couple years I'm optimistic yeah I have
I have a decent amount of cardano uh Ada
tokens Hoskins is a Visionary I mean he
was a part of ethereum so it's just I
look at a lot of the alt coins as like
stock
you know it's not necessarily there's
like utility tokens and stuff but
Bitcoin is decentralized crypto
everything else is kind well Monero and
stuff I guess but a lot a lot of these
altcoins are like stock
Mr laxative says what's the ETA in the
timcast app oh man probably months I
have no idea uh we're working on it you
know um so that people can use listen to
the episodes and everything we needed to
start we need man so we wanted to start
uploading audio versions of the members
only stuff so people don't have to use a
lot of bandwidth and you know make it
easier I will say though
the brave browser has the ability to
play a video and then a sleepier phone
turn the screen off and still listen
so apparently that people were saying
it's a solution if you want to listen to
the episodes without you know your phone
being on the whole time
uh let's see James oldiges says please
look into right to repair and discuss it
with Louis Rosman it's an issue we can
all get behind another standing invite
absolutely follow up with me I bet
that's a bigger deal than I realize
right for repair
talk to Louis yeah Louis yeah
all right let's see we'll do a couple
more here
jumping down oh I see somebody asking us
if we've heard of Yuri basmanov we have
oh oh yes Yuri bestman off yeah put a
nickel the Russian uh
xkgb it's kind of a joke
people ask that a lot everything you
know who he is no no I don't he worked
with the KGB and and like came out in
the 90s and told America like the
Communist motive is a long 80-year plan
20-year plan where they will go in and
see your culture and transform the
culture from
the Grassroots and then take over the
country that way and it's been going on
in the United States for like 20 plus
years he was telling interesting yeah
huh sorta says Tim Americans can make
whatever medical choices they want it's
called against medical advice there are
federal laws protecting it no matter how
you choose to live you are free to
choose how you live I'm 100 for people
making their life choices I wouldn't
want to make a medical decision for
anybody I'll have to look up the AMA
rules and that's why I'm like bro if I
was in a zombie apocalypse and people
were like I'm fine with it I'll be like
I'll leave
that's the thing too like remember the
smoking you could smoke in bars they
banned it all
I don't smoke I hate smoke I hate being
around people who smoke and I was
against Banning smoking in bars and
restaurants so in Chicago when they were
doing it I was young but I was taught I
would always talk to people and I'm like
why if you don't like smoke don't go to
the bar and I had friends be like yeah
but that's BS because I'm like I could
never go to the bar because people
always smoke and I'm like yeah that's
too bad for you I guess
if the bar is okay with it don't go
there and that's that's too bad for you
we talked about this before the
employees that screws the employees too
quit that's not that easy at all just
because one idiot wants to smoke a
cigarette in the back of a room and you
mean
it says it's okay and you're and they're
allowed to do it and you're like I'll
keep working here yeah if the boss is
like an unhealthy smoker and doesn't
care but all the employees are getting
sick because someone's people are
smoking in the restaurant nobody no
there's no obligation to the employees
or the employer between each other it's
a contractual it's a it's an agreement
well the manager I mean you might be
right that it's more of an owner if if
you are like I would like to work at
this bar but oh no people are smoking
maybe you shouldn't work there to be
like well I'm gonna unilaterally decide
no one's allowed to smoke anymore like
okay dude you can just leave people are
enjoying the place they used to smoke on
airplanes I I was watching that I
understand which is so gross you can't
leave an airplane and you don't know
that people are gonna be smoking when
you go in there you're trying to eat
when you're at a restaurant and it's
like oh I can't I can't taste my food
because I Smell Smoke it's just not a I
flew on a plane to Morocco that had
ashtrays on it
were they smoking no no you weren't
allowed to smoke oh the plane was so old
yeah yeah they're still cigarette lights
airplanes are different okay but I do
recognize that it's not a one-for-one
issue where it's just like either you
allow businesses to allow smoking or you
don't bars are different right you can
walk into a bar and walk right out
you go onto a plane and you're stuck on
that plane for a long time so I can
certainly respect them being like hey we
don't want people smoking on planes
anymore plus the just general risks of
being in the air and this smoke and
stuff like that yeah that'd be brutal
yeah I wonder if they've done studies on
if bars if businesses are more or less
profitable since they've banned indoor
smoking Nationwide right yeah yeah all
right let's read one more here we got
Eddie he says hey Tim my Super Chat
closed for some reason so I'll donate
again the Afghan script reminds me of
how the US messed up in Allende Mexico
and Los zadas came and kill many also
would love to see you guys talk China
with Lao y86 and serpenta
also standing invites uh yep perhaps
three for three
everybody
there's something you need to do right
now
right here at the cast Castle there is a
sad Ian but by pressing the like button
today you can ensure that the sad Ian
will be a happy end it feeds me
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
if you really like it go to timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only segment
going up around 11 or so p.m you can
follow me at
timcast and you can follow the show at
timcastirl bunch of new shows in the
works we just did a live read for the
new Mysteries show we were going over
like style and stuff and directing so
that's coming soon working on The
Branding of it it's there's a lot that
goes into making a show you know but I
will say a lot of it we're just going to
do we're just going to like launch and
just roll with it and then improve it
through you know user comments and try
and do a good job so check it out and uh
yeah smash that like button you want to
shout out your social media Chris yeah
Chris carr17 on Twitter and uh you can
find the work of my work and the work of
our amazing staff at timcast.com read
the news yeah look at this great work
yes awesome team ocean yeah all right
you can follow me at Ian crossland.net
and Ian Crossland check out that Vlog at
the cast Castle from yesterday I did
sing a little bit a lot of times Tim and
I will be rehearsing and then we get
footage of it and it's cool like behind
the scenes chilling but you also gotta
know like
if I'm if I'm rehearsing music it's
basically like you're gonna smell me
while I'm working out it's the grossest
sound it's I'm working it out you know
it's that's not the final product but
you can watch if you want enjoy yeah
we're gonna be recording a new song soon
it is so good that one said Carter Banks
is excited about yeah our new producer
oh yeah I got a bunch of songs and
people are always like oh that's the one
I'm like that was great could he grab
that other one yeah yeah this one's I
never recorded there's just one that Tim
and I had knocked around Harmony's on
for a while but I hadn't thought to put
it in the top three that we would do
first but card was like that's the one
right we got a producer all right nice
exciting times over here at timcast and
timcast.com it's really fun to see all
this stuff come together and I'm really
hoping that Chris will be a repeat uh
offender on our show here as he now has
no choice because he works with us you
guys should follow me on Twitter at Sour
Patch Lids as I attempt to gain more
followers and Sour Patch Kids we'll see
you all over at timcast.com so become a
member and we'll see you all there
around 11 or so p.m bye guys